SENATE SUBCOMMITTEE ON GAS.
PATIENT SAFETY UNDER THE ENERGY
TO RELEASE AND COMMUNICATIONS
STANDING COMMITTEE OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE. IS BEING HELD
TIGHTLY WITH THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. I'M OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TODAY WE CAN
DISCUSS THE DEVELOP. BEFORE
YOUR UNDERGROUND FACILITIES
EXCAVATE. OF AND THAT'S AWFUL
AS I THINK WE ALL KNOW IT'S
BETTER AND SAFER IT'S THE BIG
BOARD- OF- DIG SAFE BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA IS THE BEST WAY TO
DESCRIBE IT. BECAUSE THAT'S THE
GOAL THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR IS
TO MAKE SURE THERE IS AND WE
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THE
LEADERSHIP SAYS THAT WE DO DIG
SAFE AS YOU ARE LIKELY AWARE
THE DIG SAFE ISSUES HAVE BEEN
OF PARTICULAR INTEREST TO THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE AND FRIENDLY TO ME
PERSONALLY IS IT GOES BACK A
FEW YEARS AGO AND WE SAW SUCH A
RASH OF DEATHS AND DESTRUCTION
AND INJURIES CAUSED BY THE
DIGGINS. AROUND CALIFORNIA AND
I- AND- AND THE DOCTOR MARINO
AT THE TIME WE WERE LOOKING AT
THIS AND SAID THIS CAN'T
CONTINUE AND THERE WAS NOTHING
IN PLACE NOTHING IN PLACE THAT
COULD OFFER SOLUTIONS THE
PROTECTIONS ENFORCEMENT THE
EDUCATION AND WHEN YOU SEE THAT
VACUUM. THE ONLY CONCLUSION
THAT WE COULD COME TO WAS THAT
THIS WILL CONTINUE. AND IT WILL
CONTINUE WITH MORE DEATH AND
DESTRUCTION PROPERTY DAMAGE AND
THE INJURIES SO. TO HAVE A OF.
THE PAST HEARINGS THAT WE'VE
HAD HAVE HIGHLIGHTED THE NEED
FOR THE VERY BOARD WE HAVE
TODAY. AND TO HAVE A SINGLE
AUTHORITY- COORDINATING DIG
SAFE EFFORTS INCLUDING
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. THOUSANDS
OF DIGGINS IN CALIFORNIA
ANNUALLY AND ONLY A SMALL
SUBSET ARE OR EVENTUALLY ARE
CURRENTLY BEING INVESTIGATED.
AS MENTIONED IN THE
SUBCOMMITTEE BACKGROUND PAPER
OF THE APPROXIMATELY FIVE
THOUSAND. FIVE THOUSAND GAS DIG.
ONLY ONE ARE INVESTIGATING A
REPORTED PORTED TO THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
MISSION LEAVING A UNIVERSE OF
ROOM UNEXAMINED AND UNEXPLAINED
DIGGINS THIS IS WHY THE WORK OF
THE DIG SAFE BOARD IS SO
CRITICAL AND WHY THEIR FUTURE
SUCCESS IS SO IMPORTANT TO ME
AND I THINK TO OUR LEGISLATURE
SO I'M GLAD YOU JOINED YOU MIND
ME TODAY TO DISCUSS THE BOARD'S
PROGRESS AS WELL AS LOOKING AT
THE NEXT STEPS THAT MAY BE OPEN
FOR US. BECAUSE CAL STILL HAS A
WAY TO GO TO ADDRESS SAFE
EXCAVATION PRACTICES IS THIS
JULY TRAGIC ACCIDENT IN
MARIETTA CALIFORNIA HIGHLIGHTED
THE WELCOME BOARD CHAIR CARL
VOSS. WILL REMEMBER. DEL TORO
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR TONY
MARINO'S THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. THANK YOU FOR
PARTICIPATING AND BEING PART OF
THIS. IS DISCUSSION SO THAT WE
CAN MOVE FORWARD I DID WANT TO
MENTION. ELEVEN OH EIGHT. PAUSE
FOR EIGHTY FIVE SECONDS. THE
CITY A PARADISE ADRENO- WAS
DESTROYED A YEAR AGO. AND I'M
THEY'VE ASKED THAT AND THEY ARE
GOING TO BE CELEBRATING THE
LIVES OF THE EIGHTY FIVE LOST
AND I THOUGHT IT WOULD. TO
PAUSE FOR THAT EIGHTY EIGHTY
FIVE SECONDS TO MEMORIALIZE.
AND FIND US THAT THIS COULD NOT
HAPPEN AGAIN. SO WITH THAT.
WILL BEGIN AND- I THINK OF. THE
CARS FIRST THE BOSS THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR. OF FIRST
I WANT TO. FIRST I WANT TO
THANK STAFF UNDER THOROUGH AND
WELL REFERENCE THAT BACKGROUND
PAPER I'M CARL VOSS CHAIRMAN OF
THE UNDERGROUND FACILITY SAFE
EXCAVATION BOARD WE CALL IT THE
STICKS A POOR BECAUSE OUR REAL
NAME IS A BIT OF A TONGUE
TWISTER HAS ALLUDED TO EARLIER.
WITH ME TODAY IS MY FELLOW
BOARD MEMBER MARGE- MARGIE-
TORO AND OUR EXECUTIVE OFFICER
TONY MARINO. MY DAY JOB AS LAND
MANAGER MY FARMS OUT OF
BAKERSFIELD. I WANT TO SAY THAT
HAVING THE HONOR OF SERVING ON
THE BOARD WAS NOT. THAT WAS ON
MY RADAR BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. WHEN I WAS ASKED BY
MY COMPANY TO APPLY FOR THIS
APPOINTMENT I HAD NO IDEA OF
THE IMPORTANT ROLE SELF AND
FELLOW BOARD MEMBERS. WOULD
FACE IN ADMINISTERING
GOVERNMENT CODE FORTY TWO
SIXTEEN. NOW I UNDERSTAND THE
MAGNITUDE OF OUR ROLE. FOR ME
THE PROUDEST MOMENT WAS
CONVINCING MY FELLOW
AGRICULTURALIST TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE POP. AS A RULE MAKING
FOR THE AREA OF CONTINUAL
EXCAVATE. FOR AS WE LIKE TO
CALL IT ACE. TRANSLITERATED THE
STRUGGLES IN A FILL THE ALL NAY
INTERPRET THE FORTY TWO SIXTEEN
AND HOW TO APPLY IT IN THE
FIELD. DURING THE RULE MAKING
PROCESS I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TAKE MY FOOT BOARD MEMBERS
TO THE FIELD AND SHOW THEM
EVERY DAY TELL IS ACTIVITIES
OVER HIGH PRIORITY SUBSURFACE
INSTALLATIONS. WE HAVE A LOT OF
WORK AHEAD OF US IN THE SAFE IN
EDUCATION. LEADS TO A SMALL
EXCAVATION ACTIVITIES THE
REASON WE'RE ALL HERE IS THAT
THIS IS CLOSE NOT BEEN A FACTOR
IN PROMOTING SAFETY THE
EXISTING EDUCATIONAL CAMPAIGNS
ARE TARGETED AND PEOPLE AT THE
BILLBOARDS IN THE COMMERCIALS
OF CALL EIGHT ONE ONE. AND
DON'T THINK IT APPLIES TO THEM.
THE QUOTE UNQUOTE INDUSTRY
STANDARDS. AND SAFETY METRIC OF
DAMAGES PER THOUSAND DOESN'T
TELL US A LOT ABOUT HOW TO
MOVE. THE NEEDLE ON SAFETY. AND
YOU MISTER CHAIR SAID IT BEST
WHEN YOU TALKED ABOUT LIABILITY.
IF YOU'RE GONNA GIVE ME THE
LIBERTY I'LL QUOTE FROM A
STATEMENT YOU MADE IN THE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN ASSEMBLY
HEARING WHERE HE SAID QUOTE THE
WORST PART ABOUT THESE DISPUTES
BETWEEN THE EXCUSE THERE'S AN
OPERATOR'S. IS HOW THEY ARE
RESOLVED IN SETTLEMENTS WITH
NON DISCLOSURE AGREEMENTS WERE
BOTH SIDES WALK AWAY FEELING
THEY GOT THE SHORT END OF THE
STICK. AND LEARNING NOTHING ON
CLOSE. TO REMEDY THIS WE'VE
TRIED TO TAKE A DIFFERENT
APPROACH BY SPENDING OUR FIRST
TWO YEARS IN OPERATION BY
LISTENING TO ALL STAKEHOLDERS.
INCLUDING THOSE WHOSE STORIES
HAVE BEEN HISTORICALLY
OVERLOOKED. THERE ARE TOO MANY
DIFFERENT PLAY EACH WITH THEIR
OWN PERSPECTIVE IN CAT AND WE
CANNOT PREVENT A NOSE. OUR
FOCUS ON LISTENING IS HELP US
PRODUCE SAFETY POLICY BASED ON.
PEOPLE EXPECT THAT WERE
SUPPOSED TO TELL THEM. TO DO
WHAT TO DO AND HOW TO BE SAFE.
DON'T ALWAYS AGREE ON WHAT THEY
WANT TO SAY BUT EVERYONE DOES
AGREE THAT MIDDLE TO THE OR ITS
MISSION IS TO GO OUT AND TELL
PEOPLE HOW TO BE SAFE. SO FAR
WE'VE ACTUALLY DONE VERY LITTLE
OF THAT. IS SO IMPORTANT IS IT
HAS IT HAS IT BEEN TO. LISTEN
AND LEARN FROM OUR DIVERSE
STAKEHOLDERS. I WILL NOW TURN
MEMBER DEL TORO TO TELL YOU
WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MEMBER OF US. WE CAN
CATEGORIZE WHAT WE INTO TO BIG
BANDS FIRST. FOLLOWING SAY
ASSIST AS LAID OUT IN STATUTE.
X. AREN'T OFTEN IN THE FREE
EIGHT ONE ONE SERVICE BEFORE
DIGGING. THIS CAN BE BECAUSE OF
LACK OF KNOWLEDGE OF THE LAW.
OR THEY SIMPLY DON'T THINK OF
THE WORK THEY DO AS EXCAVATING.
WE PROBLEMS IN LOCATING. AND
PROBLEMS AND PEOPLE JUST
COMMUNICATE WITH. OUR SECOND
MAJOR FINDING IS THAT CURRENT
LAW AND- ARE INSUFFICIENT TO
HELP PEOPLE DO THEIR JOBS. AND
SAFELY. THIS YOU RECKON AS YOU
WROTE SB SIX. TWENTY SIXTEEN.
THE LEGISLATURE MORE. WHEN IT
PASSES MORE LEGISLATION IN THE
RECENT YEARS. WE'RE DISCUSSING
THESE ISSUES DURING OUR
STRATEGIC PLANNING PROCESS AND
WE CAN TALK MORE ABOUT THIS
LATER IF YOU'D LIKE. FOR EVERY
PROBLEM WE HAVE TO SOLVE WE
CAN'T DO IT WITHOUT SEEING THE
EDUCATION COMPONENT. I AM
PRESIDENT AND FOUND A VHS
INTERNATIONAL INC. IT'S A
SAFETY FIRM AND I'VE WHICH WAS
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN NINETY
SEVEN. MY FOCUS ON EDUCATION
COMES FROM BOTH MY PROFESSIONAL
AND MY PERSONAL EXPERIENCE. I
DON'T NEED A SCRIPT TO SHARE MY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE YOU SEE I
AM A CHILD THAT LOST LOVED
ONES. WHEN I WAS TWELVE I LOST
AN IMPORTANT FATHER FIGURE MY
UNCLE. HE WAS ELECTROCUTED AT A
WORK SITE. AT THAT POINT HE HAD
LEFT BEHIND NOT ONLY HIS WIFE
BUT THREE YOUNG CHILDREN. OF
COURSE THE IMPACT ARE FROM
FAMILY WAS INTENSE I DON'T KNOW
WHAT MY FUTURE HELD OR WHAT
GOD'S PLAN WAS FOR ME BUT HERE
I AM WHEN I'M- HERE. FRONT OF
YOU. FAST FOR I'M IN COLLEGE
SECOND YEAR COLLEGE FIRST
GENERATION FOR MEXICO EXCEPT
THE FIRST ONE TO GRADUATE FROM
COLLEGE WHEN I GET A CALL. I
GET A CALL THAT MY MOTHER WAS
ELECTROCUTED. SHE WAS A NURSE
ASSISTANT AT A PROMINENT
HOSPITAL IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
LIVE IN MY SIBLINGS LIFE
CHANGED AT THAT MOMENT. ALL OUR
DREAMS HAVE I'M HERE. TO BE THE
VOICE FOR THOSE FAMILIES THAT
HAVE LOST LOVED ONES. I TURNED
THAT TRAGEDY INTO TRIUMPH. I AM
HERE TO SHARE WITH YOU THAT
TWENTY THREE YEARS AGO. I
DECIDED TO START SAVING LIVES
IN ANY WAY POSSIBLE. THAT
EXPERIENCE COMPLETELY CHANGED
MY LIFE CHANGE MY SIBLINGS
FIVE. AND I AM SO HONORED. AND
YOU SENATOR HILL. PEOPLE LIKE
TO LIKE YOU MAKE A DIFFERENCE
AND I. WAS VERY EXCITED AND
HUMBLE TO BE ABLE TO MEET YOU
BECAUSE DEDICATED MY LIFE TO
THIS AS- SO THANK YOU. MEMBER
pCOME BEFORE HASN'T WORKED. AND
HOW WE NEED TO DO THINGS
DIFFERENTLY. AS HE SAID IT
STARTS WITH LISTENING. IT
STARTS WITH THE IF AT A
COLLECTION AND ANALYSIS. HOW
THE JOB FINISHED IT WILL BE
FINISHED. DELIVERING ROCK AND
EDUCATIONAL INFORMATION TO THE
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS. THE WAY
THAT THEY DO BUSINESS. LET AND
SKIPPERS. ROAD BUILDERS YOU TOO.
DIFFERENT AND THE TWO TOOLS WE
USED TO REACH THEM MUST ALSO BE
DIFFERENT. IT'S A LONG ROAD AND
WE WILL BE THE ONES TO SEE IT
TO THE END. FOR ME WHEN MY TIME
IS UP WITH THE BOARD. I WANT TO
BE ABLE TO LOOK BACK. I KNOW
THAT I BUILT THE. I WANT TO SEE
THAT THIS HAS OPPOSED TO LIST.
I UNDERSTAND. AND TO CREATE A
CULTURE OF SAFETY. I ALSO WANT
TO SEE THAT THIS BOARD HAS A
CONSCIENCE AND WISDOM TO A WIN.
WHEN TO WHEN NOT TO. USE THIS
GREAT POWER IF INTERESTED IN US.
SO THAT THOSE WHO COME AFTER US
WILL BRING THE MISSION HOME. I
KEEP OUR KIDS AND GRANDKIDS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DON'T
TORRENT THANK FOR **** YOUR
HISTORY AND THE STORY. KNOW THE
VALUE OF SAFETY. THANK THANK
YOU. SO THANK MEMBER DEL TORO
AND I THINK AT THIS POINT WERE
HERE TO TAKE PICTURES. RECEIVE
A QUESTIONS FROM A OFTEN
YOURSELF WILL THANK YOU AND
THEN THANK YOU ALSO FOR THE-
THE GREAT THE- REVIEW REPORT.
AND THANK YOU FOR THE TIME THAT
I SPENT. VERY CALM. THANK YOU
IS WHAT PROFILE DONE AND THIS
FOR A LOT OF INFORMATION BUT IT
DOES RAISE THE FROM QUESTIONS.
OF THAT CAM CAME ABOUT. THE. IN
IN FOR THE WITH THE RECOGNITION
THAT THERE IS CERTAINLY MORE
WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE FOR
US TO AND I WANTED TO WELCOME
CENTER GALGIANI. GOOD MORNING.
SO IT THE END AND I WANT TO
ENSURE. THAT TO YOUR BEST
POSITIONED TO BE SIX UP. FUTURE
AS WE MOVE FORWARD THROUGH. THE
AS LEGISLATION MAY COME FROM
OUR CONVERSATION THEY ENSURE
THAT IN YOUR BOARDS FOR US.
FROM HOW WE GENERALLY THINK OF
SAFETY REGULATION MEETING NOT
JUST ENFORCEMENT FOCUSED AND
THAT'S REALLY WHAT I GOT FOR
YOU OF THE BOARD IN THE ROOM.
FROM THE ANALYSIS. AT MISS OUR
FRONT- PLEADED PUT TOGETHER SO
YOU'RE VERY THOROUGH REVIEW
USES AN ANALOGY OF. TO DESCRIBE
THIS PHILOSOPHY WHERE THE GOAL.
IS TO GET EVERYONE AND I THINK
THAT'S INTRODUCED. EVER FELT
THAT THEY WERE SAFE IS THE-
THEY ARE. THEY DON'T LOOKS
EIGHT HOURS WE ARE. GET
EVERYONE TO SLOW DOWN AND PAY
ATTENTION RATHER THAN ONLY GOOD
ON WHO'S TO BLAME AND HOW WE'RE
GONNA JUST THROUGH THAT
INTERSECTION FELT. SLOW DOWN
AND PAY ATTENTION RATHER THAN
SOLELY SOLELY A FOCUS ON WHO IS
TO BLAME WHAT HAS BEEN THE
RESPONSE. IN THE EXCAVATION
SPACE. TO THIS CHANGE YOUR
ORIENTATION. BECAUSE AS WE KNOW
LIABILITY WITH. YOUR ASPECT OF
WHERE WE WERE GOING BUT ORANGE
WE TALKED TO THE EVERYONE WAS
LOOKING TO AVOID A LOT. SO WHAT
IS BEEN. SEEMS BUILDING TRUST
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY. IS AN-
ESSENTIAL TO SHIFT MINDSETS SO
WHAT ARE YOUR SUCCESSES THUS
FAR. BUILDING TRUST AND HOW CAN
THE SUCCESSES BE EXPANDED HOW
BEYOND WHAT YOU'VE DONE WITH
THE SUCCESSES OF KIND OF
CHANGING THAT MINDSET OF JUST
I'M AFRAID I DON'T DO THIS OR I
WANT TO SAY THIS BECAUSE I'M
GONNA BE STUCK WITH THE
LIABILITY. AND THAT'LL PREVENT
ME SO HOUSE AT WORK. OF.
TERRIFIED YOU'RE LOOKING AT
WHERE WE'VE SO FAR IN THE
MANDATES THAT WE ARE FACED. TO
GET ACCESS IS OF EVERY AMERICAN
TO A PATIENT. I WITH YOU KNOW
THE ULTIMATE WOMAN XIN AND
GETTING THE WORD OUT WHAT WE'VE
SEEN AT OUR BOARD MEETINGS AS%
THERE'S A GREAT AMOUNT OF
PARTICIPATE IN ALL STAKEHOLDERS
BUT WE KNOW THAT WERE WERE
STILL MISSING SOME OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS OUT THATALSO WHO
IN PARTICULAR I MEAN I AND I
DON'T I HE TO HAVE YOU CALL
THAT OUT BUT WHO WOULD YOU SAY
IS AND I'M NOT SAYING THAT THE
PLANE. IT. OR CALL THEM
RESPONSIBLE UP THERE THE.
IGNITION OR RESPONSIBILITY OR
FOR OF ASIAN BUT- WHERE WILL
THEY CHARGE WE CAME TO MIND FOR
ME WAS THAT YOU KNOW THEY- DID
THIS IN. THE INITIAL PERSON
WHO'S- YOU KNOW WHAT I DID IN
MY BACKYARD A LOT AND. ACTUALLY
MY WIFE ALWAYS SAYS TREE FROM
FIVE PLANNED BUT- IT SO WHEN
I'M DIGGING A HOLE OR- WORKING
ON SOMETHING IS THAT AN AREA
THAT THE COMMISSION AND WHERE
ARE THOSE THOSE CHALLENGES
INFORMATION IN TERMS OF. THE
HOST OF A CURRENTLY ARE RIGHT
WE DON'T HAVE DIRECT REGULATION
OVER THE HOME. WE DO HAVE OVER
A- A PROPERTY OWNER OF LIVE WHO
OWNS A SECOND HOME OR DOES A
RIVETING KIND OF WORK. BUT
CURRENTLY HAVE NO OF THAT.
HOMEOWNERS ARE EXEMPT FROM THAT
ALTHOUGH THEY HAVE TO THEY THEY
THEY THEIR EXAM FROM THE
REGULAR XIN REGULATION. WE WANT
THEM TO CALL YOU WOULD LIKE TO.
THEM A CALL YEAH. TWO OTHER
OTHER AREAS. PROFESSIONS THAT
ARE NOT AS RESPONSIVE. BECAUSE
OF EITHER THEY'RE NOT AWARE OR
THEY'VE JUST CULTURALLY IN.
FELT EXEMPT OR NOT SEEN THE
NEED. CAN I JUMP IN I THINK WE
SEEN SENATOR HELL THAT. THE.
THE PARTICIPANTS TO SHOP THEM
UP TO HER THE GAS UTILITY
CERTAINLY TELECOMMUNICATIONS.
SOME OF THE CONTRACTORS- AND
RIGHT AND OF STILL SHOW UP WE
TEND TO HAVE. WE TEND TO NEED
TO HEAR MORE FROM THE
EXCAVATION SIDE AND THE
OPERATOR SIDE AND I DON'T KNOW
MADE MEMBER. THE END THE ENDS
WE HAD TO GO THROUGH THE MEANS
WE HAVE TO GO THROUGH TO GET
AGRICULTURAL STATION. WE HAD
HOW MANY OUTREACH EVENTS. FARM
FARM- FARM BUREAU MEETINGS
ACROSS THE STATE. FARM SHOWS A
SURVEYS A SO THAT'S JUST AN
EXAMPLE OF ONE OF THE GROUPS
THAT WE HAVE A HAD A FAIR
AMOUNT OF. THEN TAKE A LOT OF
EFFORT COM. START INTO THE
SPECIALLY CONTRACTORS OUR MAIN
THERE'S SOME CONNECTIONS THERE.
KEEPING FENCING. THIS WE HAVE
HAD. AND PRO ACTIVELY COMING
OUT MEETING SOME FROM THEM- WE
COULD USE MORE PARTICIPATION
FROM FOR INSTANCE WATER- OUT
YOU KNOW WHAT SYSTEM OPERATORS.
I THINK THAT. WELL THERE IS
THERE IS THERE IS. EIGHT GROUP
AND. IN A SENSE WERE REALLY
ONLY SCRAPING SURFEIT OF PHILLY
DO NEED THAT TO TALK TO EITHER
AT OUR MEETINGS OR GOING OUT TO
ME OKAY I'M GLAD YOU'RE
SCRAPING THE SERVICE BECAUSE IF
YOU GO. CALL A ONE ONE. THAT IN
AND THAT'S GOOD I THINK WHEN
WE- IN ANOTHER CONTRACTORS
LICENSE BOARD IS HERE AND WE'LL
BE CHATTING WITH THEM. ENGINE
TO SEE HOW WE CAN WORK WITH
THEM. TO BE PUT ME AYE THAT
MONTH. CONTRACTOR IN AND- YEAH
I REMEMBER THE TEST. FACE TO
THE TEST WHEN IT LEGAL PARK THE
OTHER IS THAT THE PRACTICAL
PARDON THE PROFESSIONAL PART IN
IF THERE'S SOME WAY IN THAT
LEGAL PART THAT THERE COULD BE
REFERENCES TO ON THOSE EXAMS
THAT AFTER THAT THERE IS A FOR
THE WITH THE WITH THE LAW IS
ONE AND WITH THIS IS A SAFETY
PRACTICES SHOULD BE. SO WE'LL
WE'LL DISCUSS THAT THE. LATER
CENTER HAVE I MAY WE ARE DOING.
BURKE AS FAR AS THE ISSUE
PROCESS AND MAKING SURE THAT WE
HEAR EVERYBODY'S VOICES FOR
INSTANCE WE'VE HELD TEN
MEETINGS JUSTICE YOUR BOARD
MEETINGS OPEN FORM IN THERE
LASSEN COUPLE DAYS EACH TIME.
ANOTHER THING THAT WE'VE DONE
QUITE A BIT I PERSONALLY GONE
AND- SOME OTHER BOARD MEMBERS
HAVE GONE. TO THE CALIFORNIA
WATERMARK ASSOCIATION
CONSISTENTLY I AM PART OF
ORGANIZATION ON THE CURRENT
STATION A TEACHER FOR ABOUT. SO
I HAVE MADE EVERY EFFORT US BIG
SPOKEN IN THREE DIFFERENT BILL
OTHER NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AS
MANY BOARD MEMBERS HAVE DONE
OUTRAGE SO. CONFIDENT THAT WE
ARE MAKING EVERY. POSSIBLE STEP
SURE THAT THAT EVERYBODY
COMMUNICATION IS THERE AND- BE.
PERHAPS TO GET BACK TO YOUR
FIRST POINT ON THE QUESTION OF
LIABILITY YES HOW DO PEOPLE
FEEL- WHAT IS THE RESPONSE AND
OUR MESSAGE VERSUS. ALIVE. I
THINK PART OF TOWN LEAVE AT THE
END. TALKING TO PEOPLE IS THERE
STILL THANK YOU HI BILLY
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE THEY'RE
COMING FROM AND THE WHEN WE
WITH OUR MESSAGE THEY DON'T
KNOW HOW TO TAKE IT YEAH- AND
IN SOME STE RESPECT THAT'S JUST
GONNA TAKE TIME- THAT'S GOT A
FAST- TRUST IS PROBABLY THE
MOST IMPORTANT RESOURCE YOU
CAN'T. RUN RUN A PIECE. TO GET
MORE TRUST. ONE OF THE FEW
THINGS IN STATE. THAT THAT IS
NOTHING. WORK UP TO GET IT.
WELL THAT'S GOOD I MEAN YOU
CERTAINLY UP TO TWO YEAR START
ON THAT- TO GAIN THE TRUST
THANK YOU FOR THAT THAT
QUESTION ENGINE DIDN'T IN YOUR
IN YOUR REPORT THE TOP FIVE
SAFETY ISSUES. HOW IT IS NOT
CURRENT. FIREMAN TO CALL EIGHT
ONE ONE TO REPORT DAMAGES
BECAUSE- IT IS SPECULATED THAT
THE DAMAGES GO ON REPORT. IN
CERTAINLY WOULD JEOPARDIZE HIS
SAFETY BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVING
IF NOTHING REPORTED HOW WOULD
OF REQUIREMENT. BERMAN TO CALL
IT AND ONE REPORT DAMAGES BE
RECEIVED BY THE EXCAVATION
COMMUNITY WITH. JOSH INCREASED
LIABILITY POSITION. FEEL OF
THAT. SO. SO THE BOARD HAS- IS
IN THE PROCESS AND WERE
ANTICIPATING OB GET FINAL
APPROVAL FROM THE MINISTRY. FOR
BEING ENFORCED VERY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY A REQUIREMENT
THAT THE- ANYONE WHO HITS A GAS
PIPELINE. FOR IS INVOLVED AN
EXCAVATION THAT. THE INJURY
THAT THOSE. THAT THEY HAVE TO
CALL IT ONE ONE OR CONTACT A ON
ONE TO PROVIDE THEM WITH THE
DAMAGE INFORMATION WITHIN TWO
HOURS. IS JUST A GAS. IT IS
RARELY GAS. IT IS- IS GAS AND
THEN IT'S. REQUIRINGOVERNIGHT
HOSPITALIZATION OR MEDICAL CARE
I BELIEVE AND FIGURE OUT. THERE
IS A LOT OF OTHER TYPES OF
INFRASTRUCTURE HITS THAT WERE
NOT CAPTURING IN THE MANDATORY
REPORTING I THINK A LOT OF IT
WAS. HARD SOLD FOR. ALL THE
DIFFERENT TYPES FOR STRUCTURE
BUT. WE WILL HAVE A REGULATION
IN EFFECT. FIRST FOR MANDATORY
REPORTING OF THOSE DAMAGES AND
THE ONE. TRANSMITTER ARE
DIRECTLY TO US. YEAH I GUESS
FOR ME THE QUESTION COMES TO
MIND OF THE GAP. ISSUE I MEAN I
JUST RECENTLY MET THE ONLY ONE
WHO WAS VERY SERIOUSLY BURNED
IN THAT EFFORT UNDERGROUND. A
FRENCH FOREIGN YES IT WAS EXT
IN A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO. AND
THE. SO IT KIND OF BROUGHT THAT
HOME TO ME THAT IT COULD BE
ELECTRICAL AS WELL THANK YOU.
YES SENATOR GALGIANI. YOUR MOST
WHAT WHAT COMES TO MIND TO ME
IS THAT WHEN WE TALK ABOUT A
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS. YOU CAN
MAKE THE REQUIREMENT BUT IF
PEOPLE ARE EDUCATED ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF AIDS IT WILL. BE
MINE FOR SOMEBODY AND THEY
WOULD. INNOCENTLY JUST NOT JUST
NOT FOLLOW THE LAW BECAUSE THEY
DON'T KNOW BUT GIVEN THE BIRDS
THAT WERE HAPPENING ALL OVER
THE STATE. COUPLE IN FACT TO
MAKE THIS MORE PUBLIC AND
REMIND PEOPLE OF. THIS PAST AND
CONNECTEDWITH WHAT'S CURRENTLY
HAPPENING. I THINK TO PUT THAT
INTO PERSPECTIVE FOR FOLKS IT
WOULD IT WOULD BE A CAUTIONARY
WARNING AND PEOPLE WOULD BE
VERY PARANOID ABOUT ANY KIND OF
THAT- INTRUSION I GAS LINE
AFTER THAT. SO I THINK THAT WE
NEED TO DO MORE TO EDUCATE
FOLKS AND MAKE IT MORE
PROMINENT IN THE MEDIA SOME
PEOPLE THINK ABOUT IT. WELL I'M
IN AND I KNOW YOU'RE FAMILIAR
WITH THE CONFIDENTIAL SAFETY
REPORTING PROGRAM THAT. WITH
THE BETWEEN FAA AND NASA. AND
THIS IS NOT A- BOOK FOR LOWER
PROGRAM AS WE KNOW BUT A CLOSE
ALL REPORTING SYSTEM FOR NEAR
MISS EVENTS. THINK THIS TYPE OF
PROGRAM COULD BE USEFUL IN THE
EXCAVATION SPACE WOULD THIS BE
A BETTER. WORSE THAN REQUIRING
EXCAVATORS TO CALL EIGHT ONE
FOLLOWING INCIDENT. THAT'S A
VERY INTERESTING QUESTION
SENATOR. THE CLOSE CALL
REPORTING SYSTEM I KNOW WHEN
THE AT START UP IT DID TAKE
THEM Là MAYBE DECADES TO RAMP
UP- AND THE BIGGEST PART THAT
WAS THAT PEOPLE OF WITHIN THE
ORGANIZATION ONE SIMILAR TO
WHERE WHERE WHEN FROM THEY DID
NOT SAY TRUST IT BECAUSE- IT
WAS A NEW TYPE OF. TELLING ON
PEOPLE. AND THEY DIDN'T TRUST
THE PROCESS WOULD BE.
CONFIDENTIAL FOR THEM- THEY
DON'T TRUST THAT THE PURPOSE
WAS REALLY JUST A PICTURE OF
PEOPLE- THAT WE HAD
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE INDUSTRY
AND IT WASN'T IN BLANK. AND SO.
ANY EFFORT THAT WE HAD RUN IN
THIS THING. IT IS PERHAPS A
HARD FOR ME RIGHT NOW TO GET MY
MIND AROUND. WITH ALL THE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF COAL THAT'S
HOW I WOULD WORK. BUT I THINK
IT MAKES SENSE. NO THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION HAVE BEEN
THINKING ABOUT AND WORKING ON
IT. AS ECHO I DON'T REALLY KNOW
THE STATUS ON IT BUT IT MIGHT
BE REASONABLE TO START OUT THAT
THIS AT LEAST PICK ONE
INDUSTRY. MAYBE. ONE INDUSTRY
WITH A SMALL OUT OF OPERATOR TO
OUR SMALL AMOUNT OF. OF
PLAYERS. THAT IT EASIER TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE MAN JUST. WHILE I
MAY BE OPEN TO A- ROLL OUT THE
MESSAGING- GRADUALLY IN MANY
YEARS. IF WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
YOUR SAFETY CULTURE THAT REALLY
DOES PRIOR TIES. MAKING SURE
THAT WORK. I. CONTINUING THE
COMMUNICATION I THINK THAT. ONE
WAY OR ANOTHER THAT'S REALLY
THE WAY THE DIRECTION. YEAH I
KNOW YOU'VE ALWAYS FELT THE
NOTICED AND APPRECIATED BEST OF
THAT THE THAT PROGRAM. LOOKING
AT EDUCATION HERE FOR DETAILED
DIRECTIONS OF EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH PROGRAMS WHICH WE
TALKED ABOUT AND IT'S BEEN A
REAL PRIORITY. THE NO DOUBT THE
FIRST FEW YEARS AND PERHAPS
MORE OF THE BOARD NEEDS TO LET
IN THE IN THE EXT COMMUNITY
KNOW YOU EVEN EXISTENCE WHAT
YOUR GOALS AND OBJECTIVES ARE
IF AS- AS A TRUE THE TRAGEDY IN.
WHERE SOLAR INSTALLATION WORK
HAS BEEN REPORTED AS THE ORIGIN
OF THE- FOR US THERE COULD BE
MANY BUSINESSES NOT
TRADITIONALLY CONSIDERED.
INVOLVED IN EXCAVATION. WOULD
BENEFIT FROM YOUR EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH SIMILAR TO BATTLE
EARLIER WHAT PORTS PLANS FOR
REACHING THESE AN ANTICIPATED
ENTITIES. WE HAVE THANK YOU. WE
HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN WORKING ON
THIS EXTENSIVELY FOR THE LAST
TWO YEARS OF. THE BOARD BEING
TOGETHER. ONE OF THE DIRECTIONS
THAT ONE OF THINGS WERE YOU
WANT TO DO WHEN WE GO OUT JUST
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A
PROGRAM THAT SPEAKS DIRECTLY.
THE INDUSTRIES THAT THING WITH.
I'VE BEEN IN THE EDUCATIONAL.
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR YEARS AND
ONE THING THAT I ASSISTED IN
THE- CATION COMMITTEE ALONG
WITH OUR FELLOW MEMBER JOHNSON.
ONE THING IS A BOARD THAT WE.
WHEN WE DEVELOP THESE PROGRAMS
WE OF COURSE ARE DOING REGION.
WE ARE SPEAKING TO IT THREE AND
ONE OF OUR CHALLENGES. WAS AS
WELL. DIFFERENT ON DIFFERENT
TYPES OF WAYS TO PROMOTE
EDUCATION US THAT THEY'RE
PRETTY MUCH COOKIE CUTTER ONE
THING THAT I WANT TO MAKE SURE
IN THE BOARD WANTS TO MAKE SURE
BEFORE WE ABOUT OUR PROGRAMS
THAT IT'S ACTUALLY NOT ONLY
AFFECT OF. AN EFFICIENT AND
THAT IT ACTUALLY MAKES A
DIFFERENCE. WE WANT TO TAKE THE
SPORT A DIFFERENT DIRECTION.
THAT'S MISSING IS AS YOU KNOW
WE ARE. DIVERSE STATE AS MANY
CULTURES. ONE OF THE MAIN
REASONS THAT. THIS HAPPENED
WITHIN A MY PERSONAL LIFE IS
BECAUSE THE TRAINING WILL
AFFECT TO INDUSTRY WAS IN THE
LANGUAGE THAT THEY WOULD UNDER
AND THAT'S TRULY. ONE OF THE
IMPORTANT. ISSUES THAT HAVE. HE
LOOKED OUT WE WANTED AS A BOARD
TO GO OUT AND CREATE SOMETHING
THAT IS SPECIFIC TO INDUSTRY.
SPECIFIC TO CULTURE. AND SPEAKS
A DIFFERENT LANGUAGES ONE THING
BEING THAT I AM. CAN ONE THAT
SPEAKS TO MY CULTURE FIRST. AND
AT HOME TO FOUND. IT'S WHY I'VE
DEDICATED MY LIFE TO THAT. THE
THING THAT WE WANT TO GO OUT OF
SUPPORT. FOR THAT ARE FOR. AND
TO SAY WE WANT TO GET YOU HOME
TO YOUR- THAT'S A DIFFERENT
APPROACH THAN GOING. THESE ARE
THE REGULATIONS THIS IS WHAT
SHE SHOULD. LAW I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE AS A BOARD DEVELOP
SOMETHING THAT. IS SPEAKING TO
THE NOT ONLY TO THE EMPLOYEE
BUT TO THE- POLICE. SO WE ARE
LOOKING AT DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS
TO PUT THIS TOGETHER. WE LOOK.
FOR AVENUES ONLY FOUND THAT.
THE BEST RESOURCES TO DEVOTE OF
THESE PROGRAMS ARE HERE WITH
IT. OR WE HAVE THE TALENT. WE
HAVE AND. TO FOCUS ON THAT
WOULD HAVE HAD OUR ANNUAL
EDUCATE. ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
WITH SIX FULL FORMS OF THIS
LAST WEEK WE HAD IT LOS ANGELES
DEPARTMENT OF WATER PART IN THE
TURNOUT WAS INCREDIBLE. SO THE
COMFORT LEVEL IT THERE WE ARE
HEARING THE VOICES OF ALL
STAKEHOLDERS- MORE THAN SOME
MORE THAN OTHERS. GUN BUT THAT.
IN THE FOREFRONT AND. IT'S
PROGRAMS ONLY ABOUT. TRIED TO
THINK ABOUT ALL THIS AND TRY TO
KEEP IT ALL TOGETHER OUR HEAD.
WELL WE DECIDED WE COULDN'T AND
SO WE DEVELOP THE AN
EDUCATIONAL RICH PLAN OUR
EDUCATION OUR TO OFFICER
KRISTEN Là THOMAS AND PUT IT
TOGETHER. ON PAGE EIGHTY SIX
THE REPORT ABOUT A GRAPH OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION BUT REALLY. IT
REALLY HAS TO COME IN THREE
PHASES FIRST WE HAVE TO
IDENTIFY OF THE NEEDS AND WE
HEAR THE NEEDS OF HERE CALL IT
WONDER WHERE I HAVE IDENTIFIED
ALL THESE OTHER NONTRADITIONAL
STAKEHOLDERS OF THE SECOND IS
TO DEVELOP THE MATERIALS TO
REACH THEM AND- THIS IS A FLY.
A. I'LL CHALLENGE IS GOING TO
BE IN THE APPOINTMENT. DID WITH
HELPING THE EDUCATION HOURS
PLAN. AS YOU TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT OUR THOUGHTS ABOUT
IDENTIFY COM BUT THE THINGS
THAT WERE GOING TO LOOK AT NOW
AND- HOPING TO THE EXTENT THAT
WE HAVE THE TIME AND RESOURCES
TO DO SO. THIS WE NEED TO
DEVELOP INVEST IN PRESENT. FOR
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDER GROUPS
INVESTIGATION. THAT MATERIAL
AND RESTING GATORS TO HAVE WITH
THEM IN THEIR CARS WHEN THEY GO
OUT TO PROVIDE- THE PEOPLE
THEY'RE ACTING BECAUSE IN.
RIGHT NOW OUR INVESTIGATORS ARE.
WHICH ON THE GROUND THERE THERE
THE FACE OF. PEOPLE THAT
THEY'RE INTERACTING
STAKEHOLDERS. AND WORSE MORE
STILL AND TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
EXACTLY THE MEANS. DURING THAT
APPOINTMENT WE HAVE SOME IDEAS
FOR INSTANCE- CITIES ARE GOING
TO BE A MAJOR SOURCE A MAJOR
OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE IT'S NOT
JUST THAT THEY DO ONE THING OR
ONE KIND OF EXCAVATION.
OPERATORS ARE EXCAVATOR OF MANY
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS AND
CITIES HAVE OTHER OTHER THAN
DAY TO. THERE THERE OF. MAJOR
YOU CAN KIND OF MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE ON BOARD THEY
UNDERSTAND THEIR FALLING BEST
PRACTICES THAT WE THINK IT'S
GONNA A LOT IT'S GOING TO FLOW
FROM THERE AND WERE. THE
STRATEGIES THAT WILL. JUST TO
FIND SOME. SOME CITIES THAT ARE
ONE OF THE MODEL CITIES TO
START WORKING ON ON ALL THE
DETAILS OF THE WE MIGHT.
SENATORS TELLING GALGIANI. IF
YOU MIGHT HAVE SOME
INTRODUCTIONS. AS A FIVE SOME
CITIES AT RISK TO BE AT THE
FOREFRONT AND DEAL WORK. THANK
YOU AND THE- IT ALONG THOSE
LINES THE COMMON GROUND
ALLIANCE SPENDS QUITE A BIT OF
RESOURCES IN TIME PUBLIC
EDUCATION CAMPAIGN ISRAEL NO
WHERE DOES THE BOARDS FOR THIS
ONE OUT REACH DIFFER FROM CJ'S
ON ARE THERE OPPORTUNITIES TO
LET SOME OF WHAT THE WORK THE
TGA DOES A OR OTHER STILL COLD
STAKEHOLDERS IN THAT OUR-
EFFORT. THAT MAY BE POSSIBLE
YES CJ. DROP A PRINTER. MISSION
SIX. AND WE HAD MANY
CONVERSATIONS BERMAN AND FOUND
THAT IT'S JUST GREAT WORK WHAT
THEY'VE DONE. HOWEVER WHAT'S
GOING DIFFERENT OF OUR- WE'LL
BE. WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT
WE ARE AND WE HAVE WE HAVE FIVE
DIFFERENT GENERATIONAL. FOLKS
WORKING IN OUR WORKPLACE RIGHT
WE HAVE FROM GENERATION Z. TO
BABY BOOMERS THAT ARE STILL IN
THE WORKPLACE AND WHAT Là
ORGANIZATIONS FILTER RECOGNIZES
THAT THE LEARNING STYLES ARE
DIFFERENT THE PRESENT TIONS ARE
DIFFERENT YOU CAN'T HAVE THE
TYPE OF TRAINING THAT YOU HAD.
YOUR BACK IN WITH THESE
PROFESSIONALS AS THEY DO WITH
THE YOUNG FOLKS SO WE REALLY
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE
RELEVANT THAT WE NEED TO HAVE
I'VE DOCUMENTED CONTINUE TO
EXPLORE THAT SO. WE ARE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THEM THERE'S GREAT
RESOURCE ISSUE WE JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DEVELOP
SOMETHING THAT'S A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT AND THAT WE WOULD
ACTUALLY SPEAK SPECIFICALLY TO.
ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS AND.
REQUIREMENTS IS THAT. WHEN I
THINK ABOUT CGA THAT'S THE
FIRST THING I THINK ABOUT IS
THAT STICKER. STICKER AND CJ
WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN ACTION THE
EIGHT ONE ONE NUMBER BEFORE. I
WAS A TO THAT EIGHT I THINK YOU
JUST HAD TO FIND THE RIGHT
NUMBER OF THE CALL CENTER IN
REGARD TO MARKET ATTEND. BUT
THAT'S IF. THAT'S THEIR THING
THAT'S WHERE THEY THEY DO WELL
IF YOU DON'T. THAT APPLIES TO
YOU. A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T THEN.
AND WHERE WE NEED AND. AND THE
CALLING IS. THE GREATEST
OPPORTUNITY TO IMPROVE SAFETY.
FATALITIES. IT REALLY IS
EXCAVATION AND INFRASTRUCTURE.
THERE'S BEEN ISSUES BETWEEN OUR
X. RETURN OPERATOR THAT LED TO
WELL NEVER JUST ONE THING BUT A
NUMBER OF THINGS THAT LED TO
THE ACCENT ACT HAPPENING AND SO
THAT'S WHY- WHILE THE EDUCATE
PROGRAM NEEDS TO FOCUS ON
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE KNOW
THAT IT APPLIES TO THEM TO CALL
THERE'S MORE OPPORTUNITIES TO
IMPROVE SAFETY EVEN AFTER THE
CALL. IT'S VERY GOOD. I WANTED
TO JUST TAKE A MOMENT TO
DISCUSS THE YOU KNOW YOUR
DECISION TO CONDUCT YOUR
EDUCATION IN LIEU OF FINE IN
HOUSE RATHER THAN OUTSOURCED
TRAINING OF WHAT LED THE BOARD
TO. CHOOSE THAT OPTION. WE WANT
TO BE FREE OF FAIR BOARD WE
WANT TO BE A BOARD THAT PEOPLE
FEEL COMFORTABLE COMING TO US
WE- I'M A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER
I WORK WITH A SMALL TO MEDIUM
SIZED SAYS AND ONE. CONTINUE TO
HERE IS YOU KNOW ARE WE
DEVELOPING ANOTHER ORGANIZATION
THAT'S JUST GOING TO THE DOCTOR.
FINDS ON FAMILIAR WITH CAL OSHA
AND. BUT THEY'RE KNOWN FOR TO
COME AND IN A WELCOME THEM. IN
IN LIEU YOU KNOW IN FEAR OF
THAT THEM FOR FINDING SOMETHING
THAT WE WANT THEM TO. SO OUR
APPROACH IS REALLY FOCUSING ON
EDUCATION BECAUSE THAT'S TRULY
WITH. WE GO ON OUT IN THE FIELD
WITH WHAT I CALL THE BOOTS ON
THE GROUNDS ON A DAILY BASIS.
YOU'RE NOT AWARE AND IT WOULD
HAVE A STAYS UP WITH THE
LEADERSHIP THEY DO THE REQUIRED
TRAINING AS FAR. OSHA REQUIRES
HOWEVER IT DOESN'T SEEM TO
TRICKLE DOWN ON ALL THE WAY
DOWN TO THE TO THE BOOTS. AND
THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO REACH
THOSE AND ONE THING ONLY WE'RE
GOING TO DO THAT ON THE WAY
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO OPEN OUR
DOORS OR THEIR DOORS TO US AND
LISTEN TO US. KNOW THAT WE'RE
HERE TO EDUCATE THEIR WILL TO
MAKE CHANGE POSITIVE. OF COURSE
FINES ARE PART OF WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO BUT I REALLY I THE ONE
OF THE REASONS THAT I'M- I WAS
PROUD TO BE SERVE ON THIS
BORDERS SO I REALLY WANT TO
BRING THAT ATTENTION- I'M OUT
THERE I'M LISTENING TO. YOU ALL
THE FRONTLINE WORKERS AND I
WANT TO MAKE SURE. THAT WE CAN
REACH THEM WE'VE DONE AN
EXEMPLARY JOB WITH THE. HOW IN
A LARGE AND MIDDLE MANAGEMENT
BUT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE CAN
SOMEHOW. INFILTRATE AND MAKE
SURE THEY REALIZE THAT OUR GOAL
IS A BOARD IS TO KEEP THEM SAFE
AND SAVE THEIR LIVES. AND I
THINK. WHEN WE STARTED GOING UP
PATH WE OVER THE INITIAL TAKE
WELL AS- CONTRACTED OUT BUT WE.
A WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW DO WE CAUGHT UP ON THAT
THAT IS BECAUSE. DOESN'T EXIST
IN THIS AREA IT'S. YOU KNOW
IT'S CALLING ON THE SISTER AND
ITS LISTING CO SECTIONS ON A
POWER POINT WHICH SOME PEOPLE
WILL GET BY USUALLY BUT NOT
PEOPLE ARE TENDER. SO. AT THREE
PERCENT SIX MONTHS AND TO FIND.
A GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
WILLING TO TAKE. AS CONTRACTORS
AND- WE WERE DOING THIS AND
FIGURE OUT WHAT THE MESSAGE WAS.
WE A WE FELT WILL BE JUST AS
HARD. ALSO SET AND CONTINUE TO
DEVELOP. AS A BE JUST THE TO DO
IT ON OUR OWN IN AND REYES KLAY.
THE BEST RESOURCES IN THIS
AREA- WHO UNDERSTAND THE
MESSAGE CAN HELP US DELIVER OUR
OUR BOARD MEMBERS. YEAH BECAUSE
THERE. IN WHICH YOU WANT WHEN
THE INITIAL EFFECTIVE MET THAT
WERE YOU GUYS WERE THINKING.
AERIALS WE ARE TO OUR EDUCATE.
YEAH DONE A GREAT JOB DOING
THEIR DUTY. WE'RE IMPLEMENTING
Là THE RECENT NOT FOR THE
THING IN THE LIVE ARGUMENT I'M
TALKING ABOUT BECAUSE AS WE
MOVE FORWARD THERE'S GOING TO
BE INTO THIS JUST LIKE THIS
WITH MARK MARIETTA WE WANT TO
BE ABLE TO. BRING THOSE ON
STORIES IN FRONT OF THEM SO.
ONE OF THE THESE WERE DOING
THAT AND SHE JUST WE WANTED.
LOOKING AT MEMBERS IN
IMPLEMENTING THAT INTO OUR
METHODS SO OUR APPROACH OF
COURSE READ REVIEWS UTORRENT WE
ARE GOING TO REVIEW SOME SAFE
PRACTICES THAT'S PART OF THE
CURRICULUM IS A GIVEN BUT.
MAKES A PERSONAL TO THEM AND WE
FEEL THAT. THE ONLY WAY YOU'RE
GOING TO BE EFFECTIVE BECAUSE
IT. SEVERAL COURSES. YOU CAN
IMAGINE AND WE NEED TO BE
DIFFERENT AND YOU'LL BE ABLE TO
MEASURE THAT SOMEHOW. WE HAVE A
CUP- MEANS THAT THAT TALK ABOUT
AND I THINK NUMBER DEL TORY
WITH FIRST THE SAME THAT. IN
JUST EXIT SURVEYS OF THE EIGHT
MOST LEADING INDICATE. ON THE
LOW. COURSE IS DO THEY VIOLATE
AGAIN THE REAL. REAL SUCCESS.
BETWEEN THE SURVEY RESPONSE AND
THE. THE RESULT OF WHETHER IT
MIGHT COME BACK FOR THE BOARD
HAS A VIOLATION- WE'RE NOT
EXACTLY SURE ABOUT. IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT. IT IS ALWAYS NO NO
ONE IS THAT. TRAFFIC ALL SURE
THAT STOPS YOU. IF THAT WEREN'T.
IT'S EFFECTIVE TO A POINT. BUT
TENDS TO THINK LONGER WE HAVE
IT MARKED AS A NATION AND I'M
BRINGING THAT EXPERIENCE IS ONE
OF THE REASON I'M ON THE SPORT.
MEASURE OF. METHODS THAT ARE
EFFECTIVE. SO WE'LL BE BRINGING
SOME OF THOSE. YEARS OF STEP IN
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE WE'RE
LOOKING
SOME- WE HAVEN'T QUITE DEEPLY
RIGHT NOW WE'RE MIDDLE OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE ON THIS PROGRAM.
THERE ARE METHODS THAT ARE
EFFECTIVE AND I LOOK FOR TO
REPORTING ON YOU FUTURE AND ONE
OF THE THINGS ABOUT AS YOU
MENTIONED. THANK SENATOR HELL.
RIGHT NOW GAS INCIDENTS ABOUT A
HUNDRED. INVESTIGATORS ARE. THE
NICE PART OF THIS BOARD IS
THAT. EVEN OUR LIGHTING METRICS
TEND TO BE LEADING WORDING IS
TO- OTHER AGENCIES BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT JUST THEIR WHEN
SOMETHING BLOWS UP. SO. IT'S
ALSO PART OF. THE ONLY REASON
REALLY BE EDUCATION FIRST IS
BECAUSE WE ARE GETTING OUT
THERE AND ARE BEHAVING
ACCIDENTS THAT DON'T SHOW OF
OTHER AGENCIES. IF WE WERE
EDUCATION FIRST AND ONLY
INVESTIGATED. CAN ACCIDENTS
HERE I THINK YOU PROBABLY CALL
US BACK. RIGHT PROBABLY
THROUGH- DO YOU FOR THIS THE
ASIAN IN LIEU OF FINDS. DO YOU
FIND A CURE FOR SEE ANY OF THE
AGENCIES THAT INFO ASHRAFI I'M
ASKED THEM LETTER TO BUT- SEE
THAT IS A POSSIBLE. IN THIS
SPACE AND MY EXPERIENCE THERE'S
A HUGE GAP BETWEEN OKAY WE
FOUND A VIOLATION OR AN EVENT
AND THEN HERE'S THE PUNISHMENT.
AND OF THAT SPACE WELL AS. THAT
THERE WAS NO INVESTIGATION TO
BRING TO SAY- IS AVAILABLE BUT
NO IS DOING SUGGESTION. IN A
LOTTERY TAX I THINK OUR
AGENCIES THUS FAR HAVEN'T HAD
THE TOOL. TO DO PROACTIVE
SAFETY EDUCATION CULTURE
FOCUSED. BUT I THINK IT WILL
WHAT'S THEY START GETTING TOOLS
FOR INSTANCE OR ITS DEVELOPMENT
OF THIS EDUCATION LOW FINANCE
COURSE THE MATERIAL THAT. BOARD
AND STAFF IS DEVELOPING FOR
DOING MORE EDUCATION. DO YOU
THINK IT'S BEEN A OF COOL
THAT'S HAMSTRUNG THEM MORE THAN
NECESSARY A. DIFFERENCES IN
MINES THAT THE LACK CREATED
THAT DIFFERENCE. THE
DISTRIBUTOR WELL WANTED. WHO
RESOURCES WITHIN THE AGENCY AND
AS I LOOK THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE REPORT IT IN
LOOKING AT THE FINANCES AND THE
FINANCIAL ANALYSIS ON THE
INFORMATION PROVIDED IT IS IT'S
SO IT ISN'T SPECIFIC REGARDING.
SOME OF THE DETAILS SO IF YOU
COULD KIND OF. LOOK AT THAT AND
PROVIDE THAT TO THE TO THE
COMMITTEE. AT A LATER DATE THIS
LITTLE MORE GRANULAR. DETAILS
OF THAT I'VE CREATED CLICK ON
ADD THINK PART OF IT WAS THAT-
WITH BEING PART OF CAL FIRE AND
FISCALE JUST ROLLING OUT MORE A
LITTLE LATE ON OUR NUMBERS AND
SO- WE ONLY WORK WITH THE WITH
YOU IN THE COMMITTEES. TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT INFORMATION YOU
REALLY NEED AND GET TO. THE
JANUARY TENTH. INFORMATION
COMES OUT IT ALSO TERM.
HIGHLIGHTS THE EXIST. FUNDING
DEFICITS THAT THE OUR PRESIDENT
MAKES A CASE FOR WHY THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD CONDITION
SHOULD CONSIDER ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES IN APPROPRIATIONS
WHAT DOES THE BOARD NEED ASIDE
FROM ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO
MEET ITS OPEN MANDATE. TRUMP.
SO AND THE GREAT. EXACTLY IN
YOUR POWER. MAYBE THE BIGGEST
THING IS JUST INFORMATION WE
NEED. IT'S NOT AN ACT WHERE
THERE IS SOME DATA ON DEGGANS
BUT IT'S NOT REALLY GREAT
COMMON GROUND ALLIANCE AS HAVE
A- WHAT'S VOLUNTARY- IT'S DONE
VERY DIFFERENT FROM. FROM
REPORTER HARPER. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT SELECT ABOUT HIS.
AS TALK ABOUT FOR OVER A YEAR
NOW. THEN A LITTLE BACKING AND
PROVIDING THEM OF REAL PROPOSAL
ONLINE. FIRING DAMAGE REPORTS
SO THAT'S GOING TO HELP IT AND
SO. TICKET DATA IS GOING TO
REALLY HELP WILL HAVE A GOOD
UNDERSTANDING OF WHO IS CALLING
IF WE SEE WHO IS CALLING TELL
WHO'S NOT CALLING SO
INFORMATION. IS GOING TO BE
REALLY IMPORTANT. THERE IS SOME
POTENTIAL LAW CHANGES AS YOU
KNOW AS WE GO WE FIND MORE AND
MORE THINGS. AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS BRING UP MORE AND
MORE ISSUES THAT. ARE RELEVANT
FOR US TO LOOK INTO AND THAT
MIGHT REQUIRE CHANGES IN IN
STATUTE. AND WE CAN AS WE GO WE
CAN DEFINITELY PROVIDE YOU-
SOME OF THAT QUESTION ABOUT.
VACUUM EXCAVATION AND. WE'RE
SEEING WITH THE BOARDS DOWN
WHERE AB NINETEEN FOR. POWER
THANK YOU MAY BE REACHED. THAT
THE BOARD HAS CONSIDERED IT AND
REALLY NEED DISCUSS BEFORE WE
MAKE A RECOMMENDATION. THERE
ARE SOME OTHER. OF FROM. I
GUESS THE MOST MINOR I THINK.
THE HAVING ALMOST AS A DBA AND
STAFF IT MIGHT HELP AS DICK
SAFE FOR THEIR SOME ODD
ADMINISTRATIVE CHALLENGES TO
NOT GOING BY THE NAME THAT'S IN
STATUTES. THE FROM THE MOST
MINOR. I THINK AND WE HAVE A
COLLECTED COUNTY MONEY BUT THE
PENALTY MONEY THAT IS
COLLECTED- NOT JUST BY US BUT
BY OUR PARTNER AGENCIES PC FOR
MARSHALL AND CONTRACTORS STATE
LICENSE BOARD GOES THE STATE
FEE TO TARGETED EDUCATION
OUTREACH GRANTS IT MIGHT BE
GOOD TO. EXPAND WHAT THOSE CAN
BE FOR- INTO AND BUT WE'RE KIND
OF THINKING IS MORE RESEARCH
OUR SAFETY RELATED RESEARCH
MIGHT BE GOOD. WE'VE RUN INTO A
QUESTION ABOUT WHAT IS ARE
REALLY OUR AUTHORITY TO COLLECT
CIVIL PENALTIES THE BOARD RIGHT.
OR DID HAS DIRECT ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY OF REALLY ONLY A
SMALL SLIVER OF THE GROUPS THAT
IT. DOESN'T CATIONS ON IF
YOU'RE A- LOOK UTILITY OUR
INVESTIGATIONS WITH AND GO TO
THE PC FOR THEM TO DO
ENFORCEMENT IF YOU'RE A
CONTRACTOR INVESTIGATION GO
CONTRACTORS LICENSE BOARD. BUT
THERE ARE SLIVER OF WE'RE
ESTIMATING ABOUT 5% THAT OUR
BOARD. BOARD ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY. MAKE SURE THAT WE
WHAT IS OUR AUTHORITY THANKS.
WE MIGHT WANT TO JUST- REVISIT
THAT AND EXPLORE WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND- OUR ATTORNEYS
AND COUNCIL MIGHT HAVE SOME
THOUGHTS. OUT ONE OF THAT I
DON'T THINK. MY POOR MEMBERS
ALL MENTION BUT ALL MEN AND-
THEY HAVE. THE FIRST YEAR THEY
HAD NINE BOARD MEETING SIGN UP
FOR THAT ONE DAY MEETINGS.
MEETINGS AND THE OTHER ONES
TODAY MEANS THIS YEAR ATTEND
BOARD MEETINGS AND I THINK-
MAYBE TWO OUT ONE DAY MEETING
STRESSED TO ME TODAY MEETINGS.
AND SO IT IS A QUITE A BIT OF A
TIME. THAT THEY'RE MAKING FOR
THIS. IT'S GOING TO COME IN THE
FUTURE UNLIKE MOST OTHER BOARDS.
THIS POOR IS SET UP TO HEAR
CASES- IF SOMEBODY IF THERE'S A
NOTICE OF PROPOSED. REGARDLESS
OF WHAT THE- WHAT AND FOR
CENTER SECTION YOU'RE UNDER. AN
EXCAVATOR OR AN OPERATOR QUE
QUESTION. AND IT IS PRETTY
IMPORTANT TO THE BOARD BECAUSE.
PEOPLE WHO ON'T GET HEARINGS
ARE THE ONES WHO. AT THE LEAST
MEANS OF IN THE SENSE THAT MAKE
SURE THAT THAT THE SMALLEST IS
AN X. RAY JUST HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HEARD BEFORE
THE BOARD WAS REALLY IMPORTANT.
IT THE OLDEST Là PENCIL FOR IT
TO JUST OVERWHELM- THE TIME OF
OUR BOARD MEMBERS AND SO WE
MIGHT WANT TO EXPLORE AT SOME
POINT. WHETHER THERE ARE SOME.
TYPES OF VIOLATIONS THE THINGS
ARE THINKING ARE PARTICULARLY
CALLS. THAT CAN REALLY BE DONE
AS A MINUTE LEVEL I'M WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAL TO THE
BOARD. TAKING BOARD RESOURCES
HERE- SOME OF THE MORE
STRAIGHTFORWARD CASE. SIR
THERE'S SOME THINGS THAT THAT
I'VE NOTHING YET. I THINK IT
WOULD HELP. THE COMMITTEES ARE
APPETITE BUT I THINK A BIGGER
FIRST COME BACK IN THREE YEARS.
OR WHATEVER IS APPROPRIATE. IT
HELPS REALLY CRYSTALLIZE OUR
FOR OUR PHONE PURPOSE TO KNOW
THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO COME
AND VISIT HERE AGAIN. SO TO THE
EXTENT THAT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS. IN ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT YOU HAVE TO TAKE
TIME. TO BRING US BACK. TO NO I
THINK IT'S A HEALTHY WAY OF
LOOKING AT THE SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT WERE FACED.
CALIFORNIA IF YOU THE BARRIERS
THAT ARE IN STATURE TODAY THAT
COULD LIMIT YOUR RESOURCES-
THINGS WE COULD DO PERHAPS TO
THAT AND THE HIGHLIGHTED I THE
SUBCOMMITTEE'S REPORT. HAVE YOU
IDENTIFIED ANY OF THOSE ANYMORE
BARRIERS OR THINGS THAT COULD
BE DOING OR THAT. COULD BE
CHANGED TO. IMPROVE INCREASE
YOUR RESOURCES OR ENABLE A
SMOOTHER. I THINK THE I MEAN
ARE THE THING THAT CONCERNS US
RAISES THE MOST IS NOT BEING
ABLE TO DO THAT EDUCATION. IT
IS ONE OF THE MOST FRUSTRATING
PART FOR BECAUSE WE ARE GOING
TO START- WITH FINE SO WE HAVE
A SHORT YOU KNOW WE'RE LOOKING
AT JULY. TWENTY TWENTY WE NEED
TO BE RICH. AS SOON AS WE GO
OUT AND WE'RE TRULY IN
EDUCATION AND THAT'S BEEN ONE
OF THE CHALLENGES. IS THE
RESOURCES TO BE ACCOMPLISHED
THAT SO IF I CAN ASK ANYTHING.
OF THE BOARD THIS POINT IS ARE
IS JUST LEGISLATURE'S THAT WE
REALLY DO NEED THE ASSISTANCE
TO DO THAT IT'S A LOT MORE TIME
TO. REALIZE BUT WE'RE- READY TO
DO THAT ANOTHER PART THAT HAS
BEEN EXTREMELY FRUSTRATING AS
BOARD MEMBERS IS THE LACK OF
ANALYTICAL DATA. IN ORDER.
FOCUSED AND EFFICIENT AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE TARGETING. YOU
KNOW INCIDENT AND WHAT'S MORE
PROMINENT. WE HAVE A GREAT WE
ARE STAKEHOLDER BEGIN BUT WE
REALLY NEED TO MAKE SURE WERE
OUT THERE BECAUSE THEY WE DON'T
HAVE ALL THE EXCAVATORS PRESENT
AND WE NEED TO HAVE A FAIR. OF
FAIR WAY TO BE ABLE TO GET
THEIR DATA WE HAVE PROVIDED
MANY SURVEYS WHICH IS ASSISTED
US BUT- RESOURCES FOR. THE
COMMUTE HE WITH THE CALL
CENTERS TO GET. DATA THAT'S A
LITTLE BIT MORE STREAMLINED
WHERE WE DON'T HAVE TO GO DIG
THROUGH OTHER RESOURCES WOULD
BE GREAT. AND THEN JUST THE
RESOURCE INTERNALLY TO BE ABLE
TO PUT THIS. TOGETHER OUR ONE
OF OUR MAJOR. ISSUE. YEAH
YOU'RE GONNA END UP AND IT WILL
BE WITH THE SHEEP. IN EIGHTEEN
AT THE. IN DECEMBER OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE OPEN AND
THE GEISHA INTO P. JEANNIE
LOCATE AND MARK PRACTICES THIS
I THINK WE ALL FOLLOWED HOW IS
THE CONSULTANT AND WERE YOU
CONSULTED AS PART OF THAT
INVESTIGATION. IS THAT ON. SO
WE WERE NOT CONSULT SIR AND
BRINGING THE ACTION AS YOU KNOW
THE- FAMILY WAS AND LATER
NINETEEN AND- IN WORKING ON
THIS FOR AWHILE. AND OF COURSE
ESPECIALLY WITH THE PEACE IT'S
A- ACTION. IN A AND ALIVE IN
ORDER CONSIDER INVESTIGATION IS
REALLY BIG DEAL NAY. A RIFLE A
STRONG LOCK ON INFORMATION ON
THAT. WE HAVE. I WE'VE OFFERS-
IF THERE'S AN WE CAN PROVIDE
IT'S BEEN A LITTLE AWKWARD AND
DO SOME WORK YOU'RE OUT WHO I
CAN AND CAN'T TALK WORKS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE AN ADVISORY
PART AND ADVOCATE PART AND
FIGURE OUT WHO WHO IS WHO. AND
WE OFFERED AND. THAT THAT ARE
FOR OUR OUR OTHER. THE BOARD'S
WILLING. IT IS A SAFETY
REGULATORY AGENCY HAVE YOU
FOLLOW. MISSION SURROUNDING
SAFETY IS TO MAKE. THE OFFICE
OF ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY
LAST YEAR WHEN THEY CREATED TO.
CONVERSATION YOU SEE A BENEFIT
TO ALL SAFETY REGULATORS BEING
HOUSED IN THE SAME OFFICE OR
DIVISION. AND WHAT CHALLENGES
MIGHT RECEIVE FROM THE. I THINK
YOU CAN PROBABLY DO AND A LOT
OF DEBT HE'S- FOR OVER A ACT OF
AN INTERESTING MOM BECAUSE THE
BOARD WAS CREATED. ACTUALLY
COFFEE INVESTIGATIONS AND THEY
EDUCATION THIS IS A OF THIS
AREA. AND IT'S KIND OF AN
INVESTIGATION EDUCATION HA
WHERE WE COMMUNICATE WITH THE
WITH THE P. C. C. ASSEMBLY AND-
THE FIRE MARSHAL. SO IS WHAT
MODEL THAT WORKS IN THE NEXT
COUPLE YEARS. I THINK IT. IT
ENDS UP COMING TO DO YOU HAVE
THE RIGHT PEOPLE THE RIGHT
EXPERTISE THE RIGHT CULTURE.
AND. I KNOW DISCUSSION BEEN
HAPPENING IN THE LEGISLATURE
AND WILL CONTINUE TO HAPPEN.
THE ADMINISTRATION'S WORKING
HARD TO FIGURE OUT OF THIS IN
THE INFRASTRUCTURE. TO IS THIS
IS CERTAINLY. FOR ASSEMBLY
HAPPY. I ANY DISTANCE TO THE
COMMITTEES. AND OF COURSE THE
ADMINISTRATION. TO HELP YOU
COME WITH COME UP WITH
SOLUTIONS TO THIS COMPLICATED
DIFFICULT SITUATION. OKAY. ANY
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS. THE
QUESTIONS THAT I HAD WITH THE
TO WILL LET YOU. PLEASE I CAN
HANG AROUND A LITTLE BETTER
MAYBE. AFTER THE OTHER PANEL
THE SECOND PANEL. EVERYONE MIND
I JUST WANT TO ADD BACK ON THE
EDUCATIONAL PIECE THE TRAILS IT
LOOKED GO BACK TO THE REPORT
LOOK AT PAGE EIGHTY SIX THERE'S
CLEARLY. A BLOW IS THIS TYPE OF
W. TO MANDATE OR YOU KNOW THAT
TIME FRAME TO IT WAS A GRAY AND
NUMBER IS MORE OF THE OF WHAT
WE'D LIKE TO BOARD. AND I'M
CONCERNED BEING THAT
REPRESENTATIVE THAT WE'RE GONNA
HAVE A VERY SHORT TIME FRAME TO
GET THE WORD OUT TO OUR
AGRICULTURAL. IS THAT YOU KNOW
COME. FIRST TWENTY TWENTY. THAT
IT IS GOING TO BE A REQUIREMENT
THAT YOU CALL. AN ACE TICKET
BECAUSE LET'S FACE IT. WE ARE
TODAY WITH OUR REMOVING DIRT
PUMP FASTER AS- FAR AS THEM TO
DO THAT SO WE'RE GONNA BE
CHALLENGES TO OUR- AND GET
EVERYBODY ON BOARD. AND. INSIDE.
INVOLVED THEY MEETINGS WITH A I
HER CULTURAL AKA IN JUNE OF
THIS YEAR SO I SEE PROGRESS BUT
THE TIME THE TIME IS GOING TO
BE- IT'S GONNA BE A TOUGH CALL
FOR ME WELL YOU KNOW LET ME
KNOW AND THE COMMITTEE NOTE IF
THERE'S THERE ARE WAYS THAT WE
CAN IN A NOTE SENATOR GALGIANI
IS VERY CLOSE TO. THE
AGRICULTURE. SAID A- RESIDENT
WE CAN DO TO FACILITATE THAT
ARE. RIGHT THAT YOU KEEP THAT
THAT WORD A MESSAGE WILL BE
HAPPY TO THAT. OF YOUNG AND ON
THAT NOTE THE FARM BUREAU AND
OTHER AG COMMODITY HAVE.
MONTHLY NEWSLETTERS ARE YOU.
REACHING OUT TO THEM AND
POSTING ARTICLES. A YES- WE
HAVE. ORIGINAL APPLE RETRACED
A- ON THE VEHICLE. WE GOT SOME
MIXED RESULTS FROM A DIFFERENT
COUNTY FARM BUREAU'S BUT- THAT
WAS ONE OF THE YOUR BILLS AT
WORK TO GET THE MESSAGE OUT. I
CAN'T DO WITHOUT THEM. YES THEY
DO OF ACTUAL JOB OF GETTING
THAT WORD OUT AND ANSWER ANY
INSTANCES IN CASES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO SERVE ON
THE BOARD AND FOR THE TIME
COMMITMENT THAT YOU'RE MAKING
IT'S MUCH APPRECIATED. ALL OF
US YOU'RE WELCOME. IN NOW
INVITE THIS SECOND TO COME
FORWARD. LOOKING AT THE ISSUE
OF HOW CAN WE BETTER REMOTE THE
XP PRACTICES. I THINK SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN ALL TAKE FOR THEM
JAMES WINGATE. THREE USA NORTH
EIGHT WHAT. SINGLE STORY. BONTA.
A GOOD GROUP OF PEOPLE AND
INDIVIDUAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR. PARTICIPATING
TODAY AND FOR THE WORK THAT
YOU'RE DOING. WHEN THE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO. START OFF TODAY.
WHY ANALYST AT FIRST ON THE
AGENDA SO I GUESS THAT WHAT I
HAVE LIKE WHETHER I WANT TO
WORK RIGHT. YOU COULD YOU COULD
DIFFER THAT'S FINE SO. MY NAME
IS JAMES WHEN GATE ON THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR SAY NORTH
EIGHT ONE ON SO I WANT TO START
BY. REFRESHING YOUR MEMORY OF.
THE NOTIFICATION CENTERS SO CAL
YOU REGIONAL NOTICE SHOULD
CENTER. ONE IN THE SOUTH IS
CALLED UNDER SERVICE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COMMONLY KNOWN AS-
THE COVER NINE COUNTY OTHER
CALIFORNIAN ROUGHLY TWENTY TWO
PEOPLE. I'M FROM UNDERGROUND
SERVICE ALERT OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND NEVADA WE COVER
FOR NINE COUNTIES IN CENTRAL
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS
THE STATE IN ABOUT A- WE SERVE
ROUGHLY TWENTY MILLION PEOPLE.
SEVENTEEN OF HOUSING. SO THIS
YEAR THE VOLUME THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. WE'VE WE'VE
PROCESSED IN USA NORTH- OVER
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION OF
COMING HERE WHICH MEANS THAT
WHEN WE DELIVER OUT UTILITY
OWNERS OF THE TICKET. WE SEND
THAT OUT EIGHT UTILITIES PER
TICKET THE AVERAGE IT BURIES
FEWER IN RURAL AREAS MORE URBAN
AREAS BUT OVERALL IS ROUGHLY
EIGHT WE'VE HEARD OVER TWELVE
MILLION TICKETS TO UTILITY ON
HERE SO FAR. SO THE SCOPE IS
MASSIVE THAT BEING. I AM IS
ACTUALLY MUCH LOWER THAN IT
SHOULD BE. TO OTHER STATES THE
PAD. PROBABLY EVEN MORE- IT'S
THAT HAVE SIGNIFICANT OR
POPULATIONS AND LOW GEOGRAPHY
OR G. OF EXERCISE DO. TICKETS
NORTH CAROLINA FOR EXAMPLE DO
OVER TO ME IN THIS YEAR AND
THEY ONLY HAVE. SO A OF PUBLIC.
INVESTMENT AS OUR PAY IS THERE-
WE HAVE WORK TO DO IN IN
CALIFORNIA. REPORT HIGHLIGHTS.
I CAN'T BECAUSE OF DAMAGES IS
NO TICKET. OF ALL THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE IN TERMS OF THE
PERCENTAGE OF WHICH IS. BY
TAKING IN MANY. NOW DOWN INTO
THE TWENTIES. AS FAR THE
PERCENTAGES ARE TWENTY A LOT
FOR THE PAST REGION'S AND-
THOUGH WE ARE LAGGING BEHIND
AND I THINK ONE OF THE PROBLEMS
HAS BEEN. THAT. EXIST WE'VE
RECOGNIZE THAT WE'RE SO BIG AND
SO POPULOUS THAT WE WOULD NEED
AN ARMY OF ON THEIR OWN PEOPLE
DOING IT CATIA AND NOT JUST NOT
REALISTIC FROM OF. USE AND TRY
AND I'M NOT SAYING WE HAVEN'T
TRIED BUT WE HAVE INVESTED LIKE
A STATE HAVE INVESTED IN TERMS
TEAMS OF PEOPLE AND- YOU KNOW
THE. WE DEVELOPED AN ONLINE
TRADING PLATFORM WE SPENT SIX
MONTHS TWO. THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IT TAKES THREE HOURS FOR THE
USER TO COMPLETE AND WE THINK
THAT WOULD BE A VERY THOROUGH.
EDUCATIONAL TOOL TO REQUIRE
EXCAVATOR DO. OF THE STATE OF
NEW YORK FOR EXACT I HAD A
RECENTLY PASSED A LAW REQUIRING
ALL THEIR. THROUGH THERE ONE
CALL CENTERS. AND THEY'VE DONE
TWENTY THE NEXT. SO FAR SO IT'S-VERY IMPRESSIVE WHAT THEY'RE
AND IT'S VERY THOROUGH AS
OPPOSED TO- POTENTIALLY A
COUPLE QUESTIONS ON YOUR
LICENSING TESTED THAT ARE UP
FOR MIDDLE WITH EVERYTHING ELSE
RELATED TO BEING A- CONTRACTOR
IS THE- FOCUSED ON SPECIFICALLY
FOR YOU TAKE PROCESS. THAT
COULD BE A TARGET WORK TOWARD-
HOWEVER- I THINK THE DIXIE
BORDERS MAKING GOOD PROGRESS
BUT I THINK THERE ARE A FEW KEY
WORDS IN STAFF THAT ARE GOING.
TO MAKE IT IGNORE- FOR EXAMPLE
WE HAVE EXEMPTIONS THAT ALLOW-
CERTAIN FOR THE OPERATORS
OPERATIVES PATE. BASED ON WHAT
THE UNDERGROUND. OR WHO THEY
ARE IF THAT CLOUT IN THE- IN
THE POLITICAL ARENA THEY'RE
ABLE TO SAY WE DON'T NEED TO
SPEAK. AND SPELL OUT. SO KEEPS
WERE EXCAVATED DON'T HAVE TO
GET BEFORE THEY DIG MOST
NOTABLY MARIANNA BEING A GREAT
EXAMPLE WHERE ALL CONTRACTORS
WORKING ON PRIVATE PROPERTY.
THE OLD. AMBER SITUATIONS THERE
THAT OTHER STATES HAVE SOLVED
THROUGH- LEGISLATIVELY.
ENFORCEMENT BEING FRACTURED
PEOPLE AGENCIES THAT'S NOT A
COMMON IN OTHER STATES. MANY
STE AGENCY IT DOESN'T ALL WORK
HERE WERE AMONG FOR AGENCIES
AND THE COMMUNICATION BETWEEN
THOSE FOR AS BEEN. OPTIMAL OVER
THE YEARS I WOULD SUSPECT IN
JUST NOW ORDERED AND SO IF WE
WANT TO CATCH UP QUICKLY THAT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN. IMAGES BRING
UP ABOUT THAT ALREADY I AM
CRITICAL OF THE DIG SAFE WORDS-
RECOMMENDATION OF REPORTING
DAMAGES BECAUSE EVEN STEP INTO
ONLY REQUIRE REPORTING OF WHAT
YOU MIGHT CALL HIGH PRIORITY
DAMAGES IF THAT WAS YOUR INJURY
OR IT WAS A GAS OR SOMETHING
SIGNIFICANT THAT WILL BE
HOWEVER YOU KNOW WE DON'T EVEN
KNOW HOW MANY DIFFERENCES ARE
OCCURRING OF WE DON'T REQUIRE
ALL FACILITY TYPES TO BE REPORT.
HE SAW THE PROBLEM OF. THE
SCOPE OF THE PROBLEM FIRST AND
I IT'S NOT GOOD POLICY TO SAY
WELL WE'LL JUST FOCUS ON THE
LIGHT TO FIND OUT. EVERYTHING
ELSE LATER I THINK WE OUGHT AT
LEAST GET DATA FOR EVERYTHING
ELSE RUN BEGINNING AND THEN WE
CAN DECIDE TO EDUCATE
ACCORDINGLY BUT I THINK WE NEED
A FIRST OF ALL I RECOMMEND THAT
WE REQUIRE ALL FACILITY
DAMAGES. REPORT. MAY RECALL FOR
THE FIBER HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
WHO IS GOING TO SAY THE OTHER
DAY BUT IN MY MIND THAT COULD
BE WITHIN THE LAST YOU KNOW
EIGHTEEN YOURSELF WHETHER OR
THE HEAD THE TOOK OUT A BUNCH
OF ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICES HERE.
WE HAVE A BUNCH OF CALLS TO OUR
OFFICE FROM. THE THING WILL
HAPPEN WITH THIS FIBER HIT
WELL. THAT WAS SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT THE RIGHT NOBODY WAS
HURT BUT STATE GOVERNMENT WAS
DOWN. TIME AND UNDER CURRENT
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE- TAES
A BOARD THAT WOULD NOT EVEN BE
REPORTABLE. SO NEVER MIND
INVESTIGATING NOT EVEN
REPORTABLE. COMMAND
COMMUNICATIONS AND ALL THE
OTHER FOR. AND THERE. IF YOU
COULD HOLD FOR ONE SECOND IS
ELEVEN OO EIGHT. I'VE.
NEIGHBORS IN. PLEASE JOIN ME
.
RIGHT ON FROM. ALL RIGHT ALL
RIGHT. A LOT MEANT VERY FORMER
HAVING TAKEN THAT'S WHEN I CAN
WRITE I JUST WANTED TO THING I
WANT TO SAY IS THAT I CAN-
ABOUT FUNDING MECHANISM RIGHT
NOW WHICH IS THAT THE UTILITY
OPERATORS. ARE PAYING FOR
EVERYTHING RIGHT THEY PAY TO
FUND. THE ONE CALL. BURKE THEIR
FACILITY. THAT'S AT NO COST TO
THE EXCAVATOR. UNDER THE BIG
SAFE WORK SO FAR NO- FUNDING IS
AS FAR AS I KNOW FROM ANY OTHER
SOURCE HAS COME TO SUPPORT THE
THICK BOARD. OF THE TOP OF.
FACILITY OPERATORS MANY OF
WHICH ARE NOT HAPPY ABOUT THAT
I'M SURE THEIR OFFICES BOARDED.
WITH A LONG THOSE LINES BUT SO
IS MY OFFICE WE'VE ALSO BEEN
DIRECT TO DO THE BILLING FOR
THE DICK'S EXPORT. SO THAT'S
THE ONE CONCERN THERE AND WHAT
I ATE WHAT I WORRY ABOUT IS
THAT YOU KNOW AS WE TALK ABOUT
FUNDING- OR THEY NEED MORE
DATA. CATION SOME OF THAT IS
BURDEN IS GOING TO COME BACK TO
THE ONE CALL CENTERS FOR
EXAMPLE THE CONTRACTORS THANKS
IS NOW. AFTER. BUT AFTER A YEAR
THEY ARE NOW IN TO ASK FOR DATA
RELATED TO TICKETS SO THAT THEY
CAN INVESTIGATE DAMAGES AND WE
GAVE THEM ACCESS TO OUR- BASS
AND THEY. DATE A INSTEAD ONE US
SEARCH FOR AND SO OW WE HAVE
MEMBERS COMPLAINING O ARE YOU
TELL THE OPERATORS COMPLAINING
THAT NOW THEY HAVE TO ALSO FUND.
AIDING THE STATE ACTIVITIES AND
SO THAT'LL GIVE. YOU HAVE AN
ALTERNATIVE TO THAT OR MAYBE A
SUGGESTION OF HOW WE COULD DO
IT BETTER AND. WHAT WELL WE
COULD DO A AND A FEW THINGS WE
COULD- WOULD WE COULD HAVE SOME
OF OUR STAFF. OF DEDICATED. FOR
IT WOULD BE A LOT BUT WE COULD
HELP. PROVIDE THOSE RESOURCES
TO ANY STATE AGENCY THAT WANTS
OF WHETHER IT'S P. C. P. C. OR
DICK'S A BOARD OR- THE FAR
MARSHALL- IF. SOME FUNDING FROM
THE STATE TO HELP WITH THAT. IT
MORE OF AN OVERALL CAUGHT YOU
YOU WERE SAYING THAT. ALL OF
THE COST NOW GOES TO THE
UTILITIES RIGHT. THANK THE NOT
TYPICALLY. REGULATIONS BOARD
REQUEST. I HEAR WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING RIGHT. BUT ARE THERE
OTHER. OPPORTUNITIES FOR BEING
THAT TO. TO REDUCE PAIN THAT
YOU'RE YOU WERE MENTIONING
OBVIOUSLY THAT THAT ALREADY
QUESTIONS IF WE COMING FROM
THEM DO YOU HAVE A AN
ALTERNATIVE FOR IN. MECHANISM
I'M. WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON YOU
KNOW WHAT I DO WITH RELATED TO
THAT FACILITY OPERATORS AT
MEMBERS OF OURS. IS ROUGHLY
OTHER BETWEEN THE TWO. WE'VE
GOT OVER TWO THOUSAND FACILITY
OPERATORS IN THE STATE.
ALTHOUGH THERE ARE MANY THERE
ARE SEVERAL THAT DON'T
PARTICIPATE EVEN THOUGH THEY
ARE REQUIRED TO HAVE. THAT'S A-
AN ISSUE THERE TO THE IN MY IN
THE STOMACH ENFORCEMENT. OKAY.
BUT IF I DO YOU'RE YOU'RE
YOU'RE GREAT GOOD ALSO I
APPRECIATE WHEN HE ARE ACTIVE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
FOR. IN THE. I WILL REPEAT THE
TO LOUISE ENGINEER DIG SAFE
PORTAL AS ON SAFETY AND FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH STRESS HELEN AFTER WE GET
THE OPPORTUNITY TO. SPEAK HERE
TODAY IN. PRESENT. A REMINDER
THAT YOU SEE VIEWS WORK ALONG
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO THE
EXCAVATION COMMUNITY TO
IDENTIFY AREAS WHERE
IMPROVEMENTS ARE STILL
RELATIONS ENFORCEMENT COULD
RESULT IN ABSOLUTE REDUCTIONS
IN DAMAGES OF. IN AN
ACCOMPANYING INCREASES TO
ACCOMPANY KINGS. PLEASE IN THE
SAFE FOR THE EXCAVATING
COMMITTEE ON THE PUBLIC IN
GENERAL. WE CONTINUE THEIR
PARTICIPATION WE PARTICIPATE
WITH THE CURRENT FORM A COMMON
GROUND. HELLO. GROUND ALLIANCE
THIS IS THE NATIONAL SO WE HAVE
WE DONE. GOOD LUCK COMMITTEE OF
THAT IS ALL FOR BEST PRACTICES
SO WE PROTECT PAID AT THE STATE
LEVEL. YOU WITH BOTH ONE CALL
CENTERS. IT IN ME. TIONS FOR
RATIONS. AND PIPELINE IF IT IS
MATERIAL SAFETY ADMINISTRATION
FILMS A WHICH OVERSEES OUR
PROGRAM. I IN THE GAUGING AND
OF COURSE WE ATTEND. THE NEW
BOARD- IN PROVIDING GUY AND IN
TERMS OF THE PROCESSES AND ARE
IN ASSISTING THE DEVELOPMENT I
AM RELATIONS AS THEY PROCEED.
MISSION HAS ITS OWN REGULATIONS
IN ORDER ONE TWELVE F. ONE
TWENTY EIGHT. THIRTY ONE AS
WELL AS- GOVERNMENT CODE
SECTION IN WHICH COULD BE ACT
OF MARKING LOCATE ACTIVITIES
AND- YOU TEACH THESE
JURISDICTIONAL TO THE SI PC TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE ONE CALL
PROCESS. I CAN. THESE PER. BY
APPROXIMATE LOCATIONS. DEVOID.
A GROUP FUNDING IS ALSO A
FACTOR BY THE STATE'S OF THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF IMAGE
PREVENTION PROGRAM THE CBC'S
GAS SAFETY PROGRAM AS WELL AS
THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL'S
PROGRAMS. ARE IMPACTED. STATE
HAVING AN EFFECT. DAMAGE
MISSION PROGRAM. AND AGAIN
THERE'S- WE'VE SHARED THIS WITH
A MAN I'M SURE THEY'RE GETTING
TIRED OF HEARING IT FROM ME OUR
FAMES AS DEFINED NINE ELEMENTS
IN EFFECT. PROGRAM WICH THEY
USED TO GAUGE. STATUS OF
PROGRAMS ON THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF OUR EFFORTS OVER. IN WITHIN
THOSE NINE ELEMENTS TO. YOU SEE
IN THE MARKET WORK THE. OR
VISIT BEING FOR A ONE CALL LAWS
ARE ACCESSIBLE TO IN
PARTICIPATION FROM ALL
STAKEHOLDERS EVERY. SAYS THE
DESTRUCTION OF THE FIVE. THE
DISCUSSED EARLIER IN TERMS OF
THOSE THAT DON'T BASICALLY
BANKRUPT A FIRST TIME OFFENDER
WHO DOESN'T DO YOUR IMAGE
HAVING A PROCESS. HAVE. CHANGE
THERE WILL REDUCE PROCEDURES
AVOID THE- SOMETHING THAT
RECORDING CAN YOU ASSESSMENT
SOMETHING THAT'S ALWAYS GAUGING
ITSELF LOOKING AT WHERE. AND
ALSO I'LL LEAVE THAT THE
PROGRAMS THAT WOULD BE
ENFORCEMENT. PAGE AND
EVERYTHING THAT ONE ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY DOES ARE THEY- RACKLEY
APPLIED IN THE IN THE PROBLEM.
AND OF COURSE ENFORCEMENT
OVERALL BEING UNIFORM AND FAIR
EVERYBODY SHOULD BE TREATED
WELL. THE PROCESS AND IT SHOULD
BE. AND THAT'S HOW YOU GET FROM
EVERYBODY INVOLVED SO. THOSE
ARE JUST FIVE OF THE ELEMENTS
THAT AND THERE'S AND THERE'S
MORE THE TERMS WHAT IT IS RIGHT
GUIDANCE IN THE PROCESS OF THE
BOOK. DEVELOPMENT AND KIND OF
FOCUSING AND- MAKING SURE.
MEETING THOSE SORTS CALIFORNIA.
AGAIN BECAUSE IT IMPACTS OUR
FUNDING AND ALSO TO. FILMS IT
HAS THE ABILITY. IN INTO
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS IF THEY
FEEL THAT ARE. OUR ARMED FORCES
IN ACTIONS ARE INSUFFICIENT SO
TO AVOID THAT KIND OF
INTERVENTION WE SHOULD BE
MEETING ALL NINE I'LL- BE
CLASSIFIED AS A STATE. OF
DAMAGE PREVENTION PROGRAM. AS
YOU KNOW WOULD BE GINNY'S THE
COMMISSION WORK. RELATED TO
PEAK IN THE INDOOR CAN'T GET
INTO A WHOLE LOT OF DETAIL ON
IT IT IS STILL A PENDING INVEST.
THE OUR. ENFORCE YOUR THINGS
THAT UP. KNOWN AND WE NEED TO
WORK ON IT. IS IN OUR PROCESS
IS TO ADDRESS. IN ITS CITY
ANYBODY ANY UTILITIES AND
OPERATORS HAVING SIGNIFICANT
TAKEN. NEED TO MAINTAIN CLOSE
MEDICATIONS I'VE DONE INCIDENT
THIS TO GET MYSELF YEARS YOU
KNOW THAT. ALIVE CHANNEL OF
COMMUNICATION MAKING CERTAIN
THAT EXCAVATORS THE DESCENT AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S WHAT ARE
CONTENT INVOICE CONSENT REALLY
A LOT OF INCIDENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED DIRECTLY AS A
RESULT OF POOR COMMUNICATION SO
YOU KNOW MUNICH CATIONS IS
CRITICAL. I IN ALL OF THE
EVENTS. THE ITEM IS IN FOR
QUALITY ASSURANCE. LARGE
OPERATORS ANYBODY AS LARGE
VOLUMES OF TICKETS. SOME
PROGRAM TO DETERMINE THE CAUSE
OF THEIR OPERATIONS. IN THAT
ALLOW. THEN IDENTIFIED
DEFICIENCIES AND TAKE ACTION SO
THAT'S NOT NEW THAT SOMETHING
THAT WAS BEEN THE CASE BUT IT
HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED FOR LARGE
OPERATORS TO CERTAINLY HAVE.
VERY EFFECTIVE AND ROBUST
AROUND THAT AREA. AND WE ARE
INSPECTIONS OF WE DO. HAVE FOR
OPERATORS A. PROGRAMS THERE
THERE CERTAINLY ALL THIS FOR
IMPROVEMENTS BUT- SO WE DO LOOK
AT THOSE AS PART OF OUR
INSPECTION I TO DETERMINE- WHAT
THE UTILITY OFFERS AND FILTERS.
AS PART OF THEIR OPERATIONS AND.
AND THAT'S CRITICAL YOU CAN'T
CATCH IT YOU SINGLE OUT. TO
FIND THOSE ISSUES WHEN I
CREATED AND- MARIETTA- INCIDENT
WAS MENTIONED EARLIER AS WELL
AGAIN WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT
WE'VE INVESTIGATED THAT STILL
OPEN- IN BUT EARLY INDICATIONS
IT'S NOT A UTILITY OPERATIONS
FOR PRACTICE OR ISSUE THIS IS
CERTAINLY A CASE OF SOMEBODY
HADN'T CALLED IN THE TICKET.
AND WE KNOW THERE'S- PROCESS
UNDER WAY TO YOU KNOW CHANGE
THAT AND HOPEFULLY ADDRESS THE
GROUNDING ISSUES AND- BUT YOU
KNOW IT'S NOT JUST SOLAR
COMPANIES THAT DO GROUNDING
RODS AND SO IT IT A LOT OF
ENTITIES MAYBE. MAY HAVE THAT
AFTER ASPECTS OF IT IT REALLY
BE SHOULD BE SOMETHING
UNDERSTOOD BY EVERYONE- ANY
ROUNDING CAN HAVE THAT SAME
KIND OF IMPACT SO. ARE IT'S NOT
A UTILITY ISSUE DOESN'T APPEAR
TO BE A UTILITY VIOLATION ISSUE
AT THIS STAGE BUT IT CERTAINLY
DOES HIGHLIGHT THE FACT THAT.
WE NEED TO. GEN REINFORCE ALL
EXCAVATORS TO CONTINUE CALLING
IT ONE ONE AND BE AWARE WHAT
THE REQUIREMENTS ARE. AS FAR AS
THE EDUCATION AND
OPPORTUNITIES. AND THE OUTREACH
PROGRAMS THE BOARD IS PUTTING
TOGETHER WE HAVE BEEN INVOLVED
WITH CARGO FOR MANY YEARS WE
KNOW WE'VE YOU KNOW. THE CARD
IS DEVELOPED A LOT OF PROGRAMS.
THIS CERTAINLY HAVE VALUE THEY
REALLY NEED TO BE CONSIDERED.
ARE AND THE COMMISSION ITSELF
DOES PUBLIC AWARENESS EFFORTS
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR. AND SO WE
DO OUR PART AND OF COURSE WE
REQUIRE THE UTILITIES PROVIDE
THE MESSAGES RELATED TO A ONE
ONE AND THE ONE CALL. SO THAT'S
OUT THERE BUT BUT AGAIN AS THE
BOARD DEVELOPS ITS OUTREACH
PROGRAM EDUCATION PROGRAMS WILL
CERTAINLY BE LOOKING AT THAT AS-
FOR OPPORTUNITY WHERE HOW. WE
CAN ASSIST IN FOR THAT PROCESS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MR SURELY APPRECIATE THAT AND I
DID WANT TO. JUST HIGHLIGHT AND
I KNOW THE SENSITIVITY AROUND
THE ISSUE OF P. GENIES.
FALSIFICATION OF. LOCATED MARC
RECORDS IN THAT CASE ITS
ONGOING END. I THINK WE'RE ALL
AWARE OF THE SETTLEMENT THAT
HAS BEEN PROPOSED BY THE TWO.
BY THE- INTERESTED PARTIES- AND
I HAVE TO SAY THAT IN LOOKING
AT THAT. SIXTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FIVE OF WHICH IS A
PENALTY AND SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS WOULD REQUIRE THEM TO
DO THE WORK IF THEY'VE ALREADY
BEEN REQUIRED TO DO AND PAY
FOR. IS AN OUTRAGEOUS EXAMPLE
OF A REGULATOR NOT GETTING THE
POINT OR MAKING THE POINT AND I
KNOW HIS IS NOT AN ABOUT
DIRECT UNITY USUAL PLEASE DON'T
BUT I JUST HOPE THAT THERE IS
JUSTICE WITHIN THAT IN THE
PROPER MESSAGES SENT. OVER THAT
ISSUE BECAUSE WHAT WE SEE TODAY
IS FRANKLY OUTRAGEOUS AND- AND
NOT SOMETHING THAT I THINK ANY
OF US COULD OR COULD BE A PROUD
OF. THANK YOU AND I JUST WANTED
TO SHARE THAT BECAUSE YOU YOU
YOU YOU OPEN THE ISSUE A LITTLE
BIT AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I DID WANT TO MEANT
TO WELCOME BY SENATOR PAN FOR
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY
CREATED VERY MUCH MISTER RIVERA
I THINK YOU'RE NEXT ON THE LIST
ALL RIGHT SOUNDS GOOD AND I
APPRECIATE THAT DIRECTOR GAS
SYSTEM INTEGRITY. PROGRAM
SELFISH SO CAL GAS AND SAN
DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC AS WELCOME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY I
REALLY APPRECIATE IMITATION-
I'VE BEEN WITH UTILITIES FOR
TWENTY YEARS NOW. AND IN MY
CURRENT ROLE. I'M RESPONSIBLE
FOR PROVIDING THE TREATED
SECRETIVE DIRECTION AND
MANAGEMENT OF OUR SYSTEM
INTEGRITY POLICY AND PROGRAMS
TO ACHIEVE COMPLIANCE ROB
RELATED SAFETY AS WELL AS
IMPLEMENTING INDUSTRY BEST
PRACTICES AS THEY RELATE TO
PROGRAMS THAT HELP FOR PROMOTE
DAMAGE PREVENTION OUR PUBLIC
ONENESS EFFORTS OPERATE
OPERATOR CONTROL AS WELL AS
LEVERAGING OPERATIONS
TECHNOLOGY. TO PROVIDE. MORE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THOSE PROGRAMS
IN PLACE PROCEDURES. AS
MENTIONED EARLIER. JULY FIFTEEN
OF THIS YEAR A TRAGEDY TOOK
PLACE WITHIN OUR SO CAL FAMILY
A CONTRACTOR DAMAGE ONE OF OUR
RESIDENTIAL SERVICE LINES.
RESULTING IN A HOME EXPLOSION
FATALLY WOUNDING. ONE OF OUR
EMPLOYEES AND INJURING SEVERAL
OTHERS. WE CONTINUE TO MOURN
THE LOSS OF WACO PATRICK AN
EMPLOYEE WITH ELEVEN YEARS OF
SERVICE. AND AGREE TO SOME OF
THESE REMAIN WITH INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES OF THOSE IMPACTED.
THIS WAS ONE DAMAGE YOUR DATE
WE'VE HAD TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DAMAGE OR TWO IF I HEARD OF
DAMAGES ACROSS EVERY TERRITORY.
ANNUALLY WE EXPERIENCE ABOUT
THREE THOUSAND AND AGES ON A
REGULAR BASIS. 60% OVER
SECURITY DAMAGES WE NEVER
RECEIVED A CALL FROM THE
NOTIFICATIONS ARE A SAY A ONE
ONE CALL. NO OPERATORS AND
LOCATIONS SANDERS CARRY OUT
BEARS AWARENESS CAMPAIGN TO
PROVIDE GREATER VISIBILITY ON
THE IMPORTANCE OF CALLING EIGHT
ONE ONE. YEAH EVEN EVEN WITH
THESE CAMPAIGNS. EXCAVATORS
LACK IN AWARENESS OF CALLING
EIGHT ONE ONE. AND WE SEE THIS
WHEN WE START INVESTIGATING
SOME OF THESE IT DAMAGES. WALL
EVEN SOME OF THE EXPERIENCE
STILL TO THE CALL THE SERVICE
BECAUSE- THEY SEE IS OF IN IT.
BATES AVOID A CALLING BECAUSE
THEY SEE IT MORE AS AS AN
IMPEDIMENT AND THEY SEE NO NO
TANGIBLE CONSEQUENCES. AND THAT
LESS SOMETHING HAPPENS. AND WE
ALL UNDERSTAND HERE THAT THERE
NEED TO BE A CHANGE OF THIS
COLORS LIVES THAT ARE BEING
IMPACTED. AND THEN. WHEN WE DO
HAVE ALL THE EXPERIENCE I DO
CALL A ONE ONE. WE SEE A AND
HIGHLIGHTED BY SOME OF THE
OTHER DISCUSSIONS THAT THEY'RE
NOT FOLLOWING SAFE EXCAVATION
PRACTICES. EVEN WHEN THEY DO
CALL THIRD YOU'RE NOT A HEARING
HIS EXPRESSION PRACTICES AND WE
NEED TO PROVIDE THAT EDUCATION
AS TO WHAT THOSE ARE. NO I WILL
OF KNOWLEDGE THAT THERE IS
OPPORTUNITIES WERE AS AN
OPERATOR. WE FAIL TO DO OUR JOB
CORRECTLY AND WERE HAVING A
MISS MARK OF A OF A LINE. AND
PART OF THAT YOU KNOW SINGLE
MENTION THAT WE KNOW WE HAVE.
EXTENSIVE QUALITY ASSURANCE
PROGRAMS TO MONITOR TO SEE WHAT
WE CAN IMPROVE AND MAKE THINGS
BETTER FOR NOT ONLY FOR
EMPLOYEES. LEVERAGING
TECHNOLOGY GIVEN RIGHT TOOLS
LEVERAGING OUR SYSTEMS TO
PROVIDE AS ACCURATE MARKS. ON A
REGULAR BASIS AD- MISTER JAMES
HIGHLIGHTED IN WE RECEIVE. THIS
YEAR WE RECEIVE ALL ROUGHLY
ABOUT NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND
TICKETS- TO RESPOND TO- LOOKING
WORK SO A LOT OF TIMES WHERE
THERE'S NOTHING THAT HAPPENS.
AND AS THINGS HAPPEN THE RIGHT
THE WAY SHOULD BE HAPPENING.
BUT WE BELIEVE IN SETTING THE
SCENE WHICH IS A GOOD POSITIVE
FOR US AND WE APPRECIATE. THAT
NUMBER OF TICKETS. INCREASE OUR
MISSILE AND OVER THE LAST
COUPLE MONTHS WE'VE HAD A
REALLY HISTORIC. MONTHS AND
EVEN DAYS WERE YOU RECEIVE UP
TO SEVEN THOUSAND TICKETS IN
ONE DAY THAT WE'VE HAD TO
RESPOND TO. SO WE'RE SEEING
THAT. THE THINGS THAT ARE ARE
BEING DONE THERE STARTED SLOWLY
TAKE A FACT. AND ONE THING THAT
WE WANT TO FOCUS IN ON IS COULD
STILL GETTING A GREATER
AWARENESS OF CALL ANYONE WANT.
TO BE IN A GIVEN GIVEN OPERATE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO OUT THERE AND
LOOK AT THEIR FACILITIES. ALSO
IF THAT SOMETHING THAT'S NEEDED
THAT. WILL BE WORKING CLOSELY
WITH. THE BOARD- THE COMMISSION
AS WELL AS NOTIFICATION CENTER
IS. HOW DO WE EDUCATE ON EXTRA
STATE EXCAVATION PRACTICES WE
WANT TO FOR THE FORTHCOMING.
ANOTHER KEY ELEMENT OF THIS IS
REALLY STRENGTHENING WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO STRENGTHENING
THE GOVERNMENT CODE FORTY TWO
SIXTEEN WHICH IS ANOTHER AREA
THAT WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON
PROVIDING OUR- ADDED CLARITY
WHETHER IT'S SOME OPPORTUNITIES
AND THERE'S SOME GAPS. AND ONE
OF THINGS THAT WE DO LOOK FOR
TO IN THE FUTURE IS THE GREATER
ENFORCEMENT- AND GREATER
ENFORCEMENT OF THIS- BECAUSE WE
DO SEE. THERE IS EXCAVATORS
THAT THERE IS NOTHING THAT HOLD
THEM BACK FROM CONTINUED IS
CONTINUOUSLY HAVING TO DAMAGE
UNLESS STATE YOU KNOW THERE'S
ACTUALLY. AN INJURY OR
SOMETHING. AND JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US HERE
AGAIN. THANK YOU MISTER. IF YOU
BORROW WELCOME. MORNING MR
TERENCE STAFF IT'S A PLEASURE
TO BE HERE TODAY AND I
APPRECIATE THE INVITATION TO
COME AND PRESENT TO YOU ON THIS
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE. TODAY I'M
HERE REPRESENTING- UNITED
CONTRACTORS WHICH FOR PURPOSES
OF BACKGROUND REPRESENT ABOUT
FOUR HUNDRED CONTRACTORS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WITH
EMPHASIS IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
THEY ARE UNION CONTRACTORS WHO
HIRE- LABORS ANOTHER
CONSTRUCTION TRADES- THERE THE
EMPLOYERS- TO WORK ON THESE
EXCAVATION JOBS AND I WANT TO
FOCUS A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
I'M GONNA FOCUS ON AND WHAT
HAPPENS. AFTER THE CALL AFTER
THE EIGHT ONE ONE CALL BECAUSE
REALLY FOR CONTRACTORS NOT TO
CALL YOU WHEN ONE IS JUST AN
UNACCEPTABLE PRACTICE AND IN
ITS WITH THERE'S NO WAY FOR US
TO PROTECT THEM YOU KNOW- STAND
UP FROM IT AFTER THAT FACT- SO.
YOU KNOW SAFETY IS FIRST
PRIORITY ONE PUT A MAN IN THE
WHOLE AND EXCAVATION SITES ARE
COMPLEX PLACES TO BE- THERE'S A
LOT OF THINGS DON'T WITH-
FOCUSED ON OFF RECOGNIZED AS A
LOT OF TRAFFIC THE CAN BE
AROUND THE THIS SITE. THE HOLES
CAN BE VERY DEEP IN REQUIRE
SURE ARE MANDATORY SHORING
THERE'S HEAVY EQUIPMENT IS
ALWAYS AN OPERATION AROUND THE
HOLES A LOT OF THINGS TO PAY
ATTENTION TO AND IN FACT OUR
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS. DO IN
FACT FOCUS ON EXCAVATION
PRACTICES WITH IT WITHIN-
WITHIN THE TRAINING THERE'S CAL
OSHA REQUIREMENTS IN AND
TRAINING SEGMENTS THAT OUR
PRINCES GO THROUGH TO-
SPECIFICALLY FOCUS ON
EXCAVATION SAFE PRACTICES- YOU
KNOW. ONCE THE CALL IS MADE-
THERE'S A LOT OF FACILITIES
THAT WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH
TYPICALLY TO IN IN THE GROUND.
WE'RE NOT JUST DEALING WITH ONE
OR TWO- INFRASTRUCTURE
OPERATORS WE HAVE MULTIPLE- AND
I CAN BE MULTIPLE FACILITIES
FROM A SINGLE- UTILITY OPERATOR
AS WELL SO I EVEN IF WE HAVE
CORRECT MARKINGS. THOUGH IT
WHICH THOSE MARQUEES PROVIDE
THE ITEM OUT FOR US GOING IN
AND SOMETIMES THOSE MARKINGS
CAN BE A I WON'T PICK ANY ONE
FACILITY BUT I'LL SAY ONE
MARKING IDENTIFYING ON AN
ORANGE DELICATE TELECOM OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT- CAN WE
FIND AS WE GO INTO. THE WHOLE
REPRESENT LAYERED FACILITIES.
WE FIND ONE BUT THEN THERE'S
TWO OR THREE BELOW THAT IS YOU
GO FURTHER AND- AND WHAT'S
REALLY KEY HERE IN THE POINT
I'M TRYING TO MAKE WITH THIS.
IS OUR EXPERIENCE CONTRACTORS-
WHEN THEY SEE THIS TYPE OF
THING THE THEY TAKE EXTRA
PRUDENT STEPS TO LOOK AT MAN
HOLES. THAT THAT ARE AROUND THE
FACILITY ARE OTHER CONNECTIONS
THAT EXIST FOR POLLS OR OR
UTILITY BOXES THAT THAT EXISTS
TO MAKE SURE THEY VERIFY.
OUTSIDE OF THOSE MARKINGS THAT
THEY'RE WORKING WITH IN THE
CORRECT PARAMETERS AND THERE
AREN'T HIDDEN- FACILITIES BOTH.
BELOW THE GROUND NOW YOU KNOW
WITH THAT SAID- WE STILL HAVE A
CHALLENGE WITH THE MARKINGS
COMING AND INCOMPLETE-
INCORRECT. OR JUST FLAT MISSING
AND I THINK THERE'S BEEN SOME
IMPORTANT STEPS TAKEN NATIONAL
LEGISLATURE WITH ELEVEN SIXTY
SIX- WHICH REQUIRES WITH
ELECTRON POSITIVE RESPONSE
WHICH IN FACT IF WE'RE-
RESPECTING FIVE MARKINGS WE'VE
GOT THREE OR FOUR. A WE DON'T
HAVE A SITUATION WE COUNTER
BEFORE WE DON'T KNOW. THE
UTILITY ACTUALLY HAS A FACILITY
IN THE GROUND AND THEY HAVE ANY
KNOWLEDGE THEY DO OR DON'T
WE'RE JUST STANDING THERE KIND
OF WAITING GOING- IS IT YOU
KNOW WE'RE OVERDUE BUT DO WE GO
AND HIT AND THAT'S- YOU KNOW
NOT A SAFE. PRACTICE SO. I YOU
KNOW THAT I WILL SAY. THIS SB
SIX SIX ONE THE EXCAVATOR AN
OPERATOR COMMUNITY HAD A VERY
CONTENTIOUS RELATIONSHIP. ENDED
BUILT OVER THAT BUILT UP OVER
DECADES AND IN LARGE PART THAT
RESULTED FROM JUST A LACK OF
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN THE TWO
PARTIES. AND WHAT WAS HAPPENING
WAS EXCAVATORS ARE GOING ABOUT
THEIR NORMAL BIT. OPERATION AND
OF BUSINESS AND INCIDENCES ARE
HAPPENING- BUT THE OPERATORS
WAR RATHER THAN FINDING OUT
THESE THE. THE GUY WHAT WAS
HAPPENING AROUND THOSE
INSTANCES WERE JUST
AUTOMATICALLY INVOICING
CONTRACTORS WERE TAKING THEM TO
COURT TOO WE DIDN'T TAKE THE
NUMBERS ATIONS AGAIN AND THEY
WERE VERY AGGRESSIVE IN WITH NO
REAL BASIS ULTIMATELY AND NO
REAL MEASURE FOR WHY THE
INVOICES WERE WHAT THEY WOULD
BE AND SO I AM HAPPY TO REPORT
THAT SINCE THAT TIME WE HAVE
MADE GREAT STRIDES WITH A
NUMBER OF OPERATORS. IN OUR
ABILITY TO GET CORRECT AND
CURRENT CONTACT INFORMATION FOR
THE FIELD REPRESENTATIVE
REPRESENTS AN AREA IF WE HAVE A
PROBLEM OR CRISIS HOW WE GET
ALL OF THEM QUICKLY AND GET
QUICK FAST RESPONSES AND THE
LIKE SO THAT THAT HAS BEEN-
TRULY- SOMETHING WE'VE NOTICED
A GREAT CHANGE AND- OTHER OTHER
CHALLENGES OF EXPERIENCE IN THE
WHOLE ABANDONED LINES THERE IS
A PROVISION OR THEY HAVE TO
MARK ABANDON LINES NOW BUT WE
FOUND THAT ONCE WE GET IN THERE
AND FIND ONE. OFTENTIMES OF THE
OP NONE OF THE OPERATORS WILL
CLAIM THAT LINE AND THEN WE
HAVE NO WAITED TO VERIFY IT
THAT'S A LIVE LINE OR IF IT'S
IN A BAND ACTUALLY IS OF AN
ABANDONED LINE HOW TO PROCEED
WITH THAT AND YOU END UP WITH
WITH DELAYS AND DELAYS DELAYS
AN EXCAVATION AND I DO THINK I
FEEL I SHOULD GO INTO THE INTO
DELAYS BECAUSE- THEY CAN BE
CATASTROPHIC FOR SMALL
EXCAVATORS AND SMALL
CONTRACTORS- YOU COMMIT A GREAT
DEAL OF EQUIPMENT TIME
MANPOWER. IN WHEN YOU COME TO A
JOB STE READY TO DIG IN AND GO
IN AND YOU HAVE ALL THOSE
RESOURCES ON THE LINE AND YOU
HAVE TO STOP WITH PROJECT YOU
HAVE YOU HAVE MONEY GOING OUT
THE WINDOW IT IS TIME GOES BY
AND THAT'S THE CAN BE EXTREMELY
DAMAGING PUT SMALL CONTRACT OUT
OF BUSINESS- SO THE AND ON TOP
OF THAT THERE COULD BE
LIQUIDATED DAMAGES A LOT OF
THESE EXCAVATIONS ARE SHORT
TIME LINES. AND OPINIONS HAS A
PROJECT CAN RENT FROM THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS UP TO MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS PER DAY THAT THOSE
PROJECTS GO OVER SO THAT CAN
BE- AS EXTREME CHALLENGE AND WE
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO PUT AN
EXCAVATOR IN A SITUATION WHERE
THEY MAKE A BAD CHOICE. BASED
ON THE SUBJECTED FINANCIAL
IMPACT IT COULD HAVE OVER THE
PRUDENT IN THEIR SAFETY
PRACTICES IN THE WHOLE SO
THAT'S SOMETHING TO LOOK AT TO-
ANOTHER THING WE WERE
ADDRESSING THIS YEAR WITH THE
BOARD AND BEEN ACTIVE
PARTICIPANTS IN IS THE.
NINETEEN FOURTEEN A- DEALING
WITH. DIFFICULT SOILS. THAT CAN
ALSO. A SAFETY PROBLEM FOR OUR
MEN IN THE WHOLE BECAUSE IF YOU
GET TO A DEEP. DEEP FACILITY OR
VERY DIFFICULT FOR US TO DO YOU
DEAL WITH AND YOU'RE HAVING
HAND TOOL OR USE FOR. USE INTO-
PROCEDURES THAT ARE INEFFECTIVE
THEY CAN PUT A MAN AT RISK IN
AND WE NOW HAVE OPTIONS OR
WORKING THROUGH. IN OTHER MORE
PROOF METHODS TO GET TO
FACILITY SAFELY. BE ABLE ACCESS
THEM INTO WHAT WE NEED TO DO.
YOU KNOW EDUCATION IS THE
CONTINUED IMPORTANCE AND IN
WHAT WE'VE TRIED TO DO IS AN
ASSOCIATION. IS TO RAISE
AWARENESS THROUGH ARC FOR OUR
CONTRACTORS OF THE IMPORTANCE
OF THE NEW BOARD I SAY NEW
BOARDS COUPLE USED A FEW YEARS
OLD BUT IT'S STILL NEW TO OUR
GUYS- THERE'S DIFFERENT YOU
KNOW SOME. INITIALLY THEY
LOOKED AT SKIP SKEPTICALLY BUT
NOW THEY'RE STARTING TO REALIZE
THAT THIS CAN BE A RESOURCE FOR
THEM. YOU CAN BE ACTUALLY PLACE
WHEN THEY COME TO WORK THROUGH
DIFFERENCES WITH OPERATORS IN
THE CAN BE A NEUTRAL GROUND
WHERE WE CAN MEDIATE THROUGH
THOSE THOSE DIFFERENCES AND
PROBLEMS AND COME TO SOLUTIONS
SO.  PARTNERSHIP BUT I CAN I
CAN ATTEST TO WITH THE DE BOARD
WAS SAYING EARLIER ABOUT THE-
CHALLENGE THEY'RE FACED WITH
TRYING TO EDUCATE EVERYONE- WE
FOUND CHALLENGES JUST GETTING
THE WORD OUT TO ALL OF OUR
GUYS. AND GETTING THEM TO
ENGAGE AND CERTAINLY THROUGHOUT
THE STATE THERE'S SUCH A- VAST.
AB EVERYBODY CAN BE AS COMMUTER
AT SOME POINT AND JUST GETTING
THE WORD OUT THIS. IS CAN BE
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT SO. I IN
GETTING YOU KNOW IT WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER GETTING
INFORMATION BACK TO THE
OPERATORS TO IF WE EXPERIENCE
YOU'LL FIND CASES WHERE WE COME
ACROSS THERE'S THEIR
FACILITIES. AND THERE ARE NEXT
THAT ARE ALREADY THERE ARE
THERE'S PATCHES OR SOMETHING
SOME OF YOUR REPORT BEFORE.
BEING ABLE TO SHARE THAT
INFORMATION BE PARTNERS IN THE
AND IN MAPPING THESE-
FACILITIES IT MAY NOT BE SO YOU
KNOW MAYBE OLDER OR NOT- WELL
MAPPED- FOR IN THE PAST
INSISTED THAT SUMMER Và. YOU
KNOW DECADES OLD UP IN MANY
DECADES OLD- WITH THAT SAID
THOUGH WE SHOULDN'T A COMMUTER
SHOULD BE SEEN AS- IS LOCATORS-
OR- I SHOULD SAY. USES LOCATORS
BECAUSE WE HAVE WE DO SEE
INSTANCES WHERE LOCATED MARK
WILL COME OUT AND- DESIGNATE IN
YEARS MARKET A LARGE AREA WITH
QUESTION MARKS AND SAY DELIGHT.
IN IN THE SENSE OF THEIR
STARTING THAT THE EXCAVATOR.
NEEDS TO DAYLIGHT ALL
FACILITIES. ARE IN THAT THAT
ROUND. REGARDLESS OF IF THAT'S
IN CONFLICT. WITH THEIR THEIR
ACTUAL EXCAVATION IN THAT'S
ABUSE OF THAT. THAT POWER IN A
IN I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE- NEED TO WORK THROUGH
BUT IN IN THE WAYS THAT WE CAN
GET THE- THE- AS DRAW LINES-
PLANS CORRECED WHERE THEY WERE
BUILT A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY
AND WE SEE VARIANCES THAT COME
INTO PLAY AND- HAVE SAFELY BEEN
DISCOVERED AND- THAT'S WHERE WE
ARE KEY PARTNERS IN THIS. BUT
AS I MENTIONED IS A STAR THIS
EXAMINERS COME IN ALL SHAPES
SIZES AND PURPOSES. FOR MOST
PART WE ARE THE LARGE MORE
SOPHISTICATED OPERATIONS BUT WE
ARE ALSO THE ONES WERE IN THE
HOLES- THE EXPERIENCING THE
MOST CHALLENGES WITH. WITH THE
MOST FACILITIES AT ANY GIVEN
TIME SO. I APPRECIATE THAT- THE
OPPORTUNITY COME HERE TODAY AND
AN OPEN ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE THANK YOU IF YOU ARE A AND
I DO HAVE ONE. THAT THE- WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS
WOULD. CENTERS FRESH IN MY MIND
AND AFTER- YOUR PRESENTATION.
IN THIS CASE. IS SOMETHING WAS
REFLECTED IN THE- THE-
COMMITTEE HEARING. SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARING WE HAD AN BAKERSFIELD
AND A LOT OF THE. A LOT OF
INFORMATION CAME TO LIGHT SOME
OF THE ISSUES SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS OF THE CHALLENGES
BETWEEN THE CONTRACTOR AND THE
OPERATOR THE UTILITIES. AND
THEN AFTER THAT- I. IN THE CITY
OF SAN BRUNO THEY'RE DOING A
GREAT SEPARATION ON THAT
CALTRAIN LINE AND- THERE WAS A
DAY AGAIN- THE- EVACUATED- NO
ONE WAS INJURED. THERE WAS NO.
EXPLOSION OR FIRE- THEN- P.
JEANNIE CAME OUT THERE THE
PROVIDER AT THAT AT THAT
LOCATION. AND AS THEY WERE
STANDING THERE THE PEOPLE FROM-
THE CALTRAIN THE EMPLOYEES WERE
STANDING OVER THE SITE AND
THERE WAS A- DEPUTY SHERIFF
THAT IN THERE AND- THE P.
JEANNIE FELLOW. WAS THERE ANY
TAKES HIS BREAK CANNOT STARTS
BRAIN IN THE WHOLE. BASICALLY
TO ME IT LOOKED LIKE HE WAS
COVERED IN WHATEVER WAS GOING
ON AND WAS MAYBE MIS MARKED AND%
TRYING TO CORRECT THAT THAT WAS
AN ISSUE THAT WAS RAISED IN THE
HEARING THAT WE HAD A
BAKERSFIELD ONE TO THE OTHER
ISSUE WAS THE MISS MARKING OF
THIS FROM SOME OF THE UTILITIES
AND- SO I GUESS THE QUESTION IS
DO YOU STILL FIND THAT AS A
PROBLEM AND HOW EXTENSIVE IS
IT- AND HAS THAT- SUBSIDED IN
ANY ANYWAY SINCE- THE LAST FEW
YEARS. THE WITH REGARD TO THE
FIRST POINT WHERE IF SOMEBODY
FOLLOWING UP WITH KIND OF AFTER
THE FACT YEAH MARKINGS THAT IS
SOMETHING WE ENCOUNTERED
REPEATEDLY EVEN A ROUTE BEFORE
AND AFTER THAT THAT INCIDENT
AND IT WAS SOMETHING THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN KIND OF A- I WAS A
COMMON PRACTICE BUT IT WAS
CERTAINLY SEEM BAD LUMBAR
MEMBER CONTRACTORS WE HAVEN'T
SEEN SO MUCH OF THAT AS OF LATE
SO I THINK THAT'S SOMEWHAT
RESOLVED ITSELF IN IN- AS
TIME'S GONE BY AND ENJOY
AWARENESS TO THIS ISSUE IS
TAKING PLACE. AS FAR AS MISS
MARKS ARE CONCERNED IT'S STILL
HAPPENING- NO MARKS MISS MARKS
ALL OF THAT IT'S THERE IS A LOT
OF VOLUME IN THE MARKS- THAT
THE TO THE OPERATORS HAVE TO
MAKE- AND I KNOW THAT THE SOME
OF THE DRAWINGS ARE OLDER BUT
THERE ARE CASES WHERE THERE
BLATANT MISS MARKS AND WE'RE
GOING IN AND REFINING
FACILITIES WEREN'T EVEN NOTATED
THAT WERE IN THE GROUND AND
IT'S COMING DOWN AND TO DO
PRUDENCE ON THE EXTERIORS PART
TO BE CAREFUL NOT TO JUST. YOU
KNOW GO IN AND POSSIBLY STRIKE
THE UNKNOWN AS WELL SO- YES
IT'S STILL HAPPENING- AGAIN-
IT'S IT COMES DOWN TO US
WORKING AS PARTNERS TO MAKE
SURE WE COMPLETE THOSE RECORDS
TO THE BEST WE CAN. UPDATE ALL
RECORDS BUT ALSO YOU KNOW.
RECOGNIZING THAT THE OPERATORS
HAVE TO BE GOOD PARTNERS IN
GETTING THOSE TYPE MARKINGS
TIMELY INCORRECT OR WE CAN
MISTAKES HAPPEN IN ALL CASES.
BUT THERE ARE INSTANCES WHERE
THEY JUST NOT BEING CAREFUL OR
WE ARE SEEING- COMPANIES WERE
AYE HIRING THIRD PARTY-
LOCATORS. THAT AREN'T. I WILL
SAY SUFFICIENTLY TRAINED TO
RECOGNIZE FACILITIES AND IN
SOME INSTANCES RESULT IN ERRORS
AND MARKINGS IN THAT CASE AS
WELL. THANK YOU- THE YES JOIN
DATE. COULD RAISE ADEQUATE NO
TO THAT- AT THE AT THE CALL%
CENTERS WE EXPERIENCE
COMPLAINTS ABOUT MISS MARKS AND
NO MARKS LATE MARK'S DAILY MANY
TIMES DAILY. AND ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT HAS BEEN ON MY
RADAR FOR AWHILE AND I'M NOT
SURE WHERE THE APPROPRIATE
PLACE TO PUT THIS IN IS THAT.
YOU KNOW SOME OF THIS IS A
LIMITATION IN TECHNOLOGY THE
ACTUAL INSTRUMENTS TO
PHYSICALLY DETECT WHERE THE
FACILITIES ARE THERE THERE IS.
IMPROVEMENT THAT NEEDS TO BE
MADE IN THAT INDUSTRY BUT YOU
KNOW THE FACILITY OPERATORS
THEY CAN'T HELP OUT UNTIL SOME
INVENTOR COMES UP WITH THE NEXT
BIG THING TO ACTUALLY SOLVE
THAT HOWEVER. THE RECORD
KEEPING THAT MUST FAR AHEAD ON
IS KEY AND- I WOULD LOVE TO SEE
A BEST PRACTICE WHERE. ALL NEW
ALL FACILITIES WHEN THEY'RE
EXPOSED. TO DAYLIGHT OUR GPS
MEANING ALL NEW INSTALLATIONS
GET A RECORD BY GPS
REPLACEMENTS RELOCATIONS
REPAIRS EVERYTHING GETS DPS
BEFORE IT GETS BURIED THAT DOES
NOT OCCUR NOW NOT BY A LONG
SHOT NOT EVEN NEW INSTALLATIONS
BRAND NEW STUFF IS BEING GPS.
SOME FACILITY OPERATORS WILL DO
IT GOOD ONES BUT OTHERS WILL
NOT DO IT UNLESS THEY'RE
REQUIRED IS INCLUDE
MUNICIPALITIES GAS COMPANIES
TELECOM EVERY SECTOR. SO IF
WE'RE GOING TO. MAKE PROGRESS
BEAT WITH ALL THESE LINES ARE
BEING DISCOVERED- BY EXCAVATORS
ARE WE JUST GONNA BE CONTENT TO
LET THAT BE THE CASE THAT SOME
OF THE OVER THERE AND WE KNOW
IT'S THERE BUT WE DON'T KNOW
WHERE AND WE'RE JUST GONNA
EXCEPT THAT FOREVER. THEN WE
KEEP GOING AS BUSINESS AS USUAL
BUT IF WE WANT TO HAVE THIS BE
SOLVED IN TIME IS STILL GONNA
TAKE DECADES. BUT THE WE'VE GOT
TO GET STARTED AND THAT'S THE
EASIEST UP IS START WITH THE
NEW INSTALLATIONS AND THEN THE
REPAIR OBVIOUSLY CAN'T DIG
EVERYTHING UP JUST THE MAP IT
BUT AS IT DOES GET DUG UP FOR
OTHER PURPOSES REPAIR REPLACE
IT RELOCATE THAT'S WHEN THE GPS
IN OVERTIME. WE WILL HAVE GOOD
RECORDS SO THAT THAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN. THANK YOU FOR THAT. Và
RIVERA WE JUST WANTED OFFER OUR
CONDOLENCES AND HOW SORRY WE
ARE FOR YOUR LOSS AND THE
MYRIAD EXPLOSION AND HOW YOUR
FAMILY'S AND OF STRUGGLING AND
SUFFERING BECAUSE OF THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OFFER THAT.
HAVE FOR. YOU WHAT HAVE WE
LEARNED FROM THAT EXPLOSION I
MEAN DID WE LEARN IN AND WHAT.
DO YOU SEE ANYTHING THAT WE CAN
DO OR SHOULD BE DONE
DIFFERENTLY TO PREVENT THOSE IN
THE FUTURE. WELL A ELECTION YOU
MENTION- SALE MENTIONED EARLIER
THE MEDIC MEDICATION STILL
PENDING- BUT SOME OF A QUICK
THING THAT WE DID. I AM LOOKING
FOR OPPORTUNITY YOU KNOW WE
HAVE OUR PUBLIC WORDS CAMPAIGNS
IT GOES OUT TO SPECIFIC
EXCAVATORS. THAT WE HAVE SO.
FROM THAT IN THE IMMEDIATE.
AWARENESS WE REALIZE THAT WE
WEREN'T TOUCHING A CERTAIN
CATEGORY OF EXCAVATORS WHO TRY
TO LOOK AT EXPANDING. A
COMMUNICATION THAT GOES OUT-
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT AND IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT. MARGIE'S
FROM THE DEPARTMENT CHEN IS
LIKE. HOW WHICH BOOK IS OUR
MESSAGING TO DIFFERENT TYPES OF
EXCAVATORS I'M COOLEY NORMALLY
HISTORICALLY WE HAVE WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO TARGET A SPECIFIC
AUDIENCE. WE REALIZE THAT WE
TARGET MULTIPLE AUDIENCES GOOD
MULTIPLE PEOPLE CAN BE
EXCAVATORS WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE AWARE. OF HAVING TO
CALL YOU ONE ONE OR THIS IS A
FREE SERVICE FOR THEM IT
ACTUALLY CALL. AND LOOKING AT
BILLY THE LEGISLATION TO SEE
WHERE WE'RE- WORKING WITH
DRINKING THING TO KIND OF MAKE
MAKE IMPROVEMENTS. NO ONE AREA
THAT WE SAW. WITH THE
GOVERNMENT CODE FORTY TWO
SIXTEEN IS THE DEFINITION OF
EXCAVATION SOME PEOPLE HAVE.
THE REDEFINITION AND EXPLICITLY
THINK THAT'S WHAT IS IT IF I'M
NOT DOING THIS NOT EXCAVATING
BUT IT'S REALLY. CAN FULLY
UNDERSTAND THE TIME I'M I'M
REALLY MOVING SOIL. THAT
BECOMES AN EXCAVATION OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S SOME IMPLICATIONS OF
THAT WE WANT TO BE SENSITIVE TO
THAT AS WELL. THE BILL STOLE
SOME OF. THINGS THAT WE STARTED
LEARNING NOW AND IT WILL BE
EXPANDING THAT AWARENESS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAUDHRY AND I'M AN
ASPEN TOMORROW USE THAT AS WELL
AND IS THERE ANY. THINGS THAT
WE'VE TAKE AWAYS FROM THAT
THAT- WE CAN USE AS YOUR BEST
PRACTICES OR WHAT WE SHOULD BE
DOING TO EDUCATE OR SOMETHING
IN THE FUTURE. I THINK UP
PARTICIPATING WITH CARMEN AND-
IT CONTINUES TO BE THIS BIG
AREA ABOUT. ARE YOU KNOW
WHETHER NOT PERMITS REQUIRED
FOR THE WORK AND WHAT AT WHAT
POINT DOES THAT THEN GO TO ONE
A ONE ONE REQUIREMENT. HOW TO
CALL. SO I THINK JUST. PERHAPS
A LOT MORE CLARITY ON THAT END.
IN TERMS OF THE PERMIT AND THE
TYPE OF WORK BEING DONE- THAT
THEN MOVES TO THE PHASE OF.
YOUR DIGGING SOMEWHERE WHERE
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
UNDERNEATH. AND YOU NEED TO
PULL A TICKET SO I THINK IT'S
JUST A- IT IT IT STILL. TENDS
TO BE AN AREA THAT THAT'S RIGHT
BEFORE- BEFORE WE A LOT MORE
CLARITY IN A LOT MORE. GUIDANCE
TO FOLKS AND I THINK OUR GUYS.
KIND OF TAKING IT ON AS AN ITEM
I THINK IT'S AND ONE OF THE
GROUPS LIKE I'M ON SO MANY
DIFFERENT GROUPS I GET CONFUSED
BUT- YOU KNOW THAT THAT INTENT.
WHAT COULD WE DO TO PROVIDE
MORE CLARITY OR OR SOME SORT OF
AN EASY. A PLACE FOR HOMEOWNERS
AND OTHERS TO GO TO DON'T KIND
OF IDENTIFY OKAY I'M PLANNING A
PLAN I DON'T NEED TO DO. I TAKE
IT. BUT IF I'M PULLING A PERMIT
THAT CERTAINLY MAKES IT A
TICKET REQUIREMENTS- IN IN SO
JUST. YOUNG WE COULD CERTAINLY
WORK ON CLARIFYING THAT IN
MAKING THAT A LOT MORE KNOWN TO
EVERYBODY INVOLVED. THANK YOU
AND IF I COULD JUST ADD TO THAT
YOU KNOW WHEN WE WERE DEBATING
THAT LEGISLATION ORIGINAL SIX
SIX ONE LEGISLATION THIS. CAME
UP TO QUITE SOME EXTENT AND IT
WAS WITH DIFFICULTY THAT WE
WEREN'T ABLE TO ADDRESS IT
ULTIMATELY. IN THE END RESERVE
BECAME TO HOMEOWNERS IN SOME
INSTANCES LIKE THAT AND- TALK
ABOUT YEAR TALK ABOUT DRIVING A
STAKE INTO THE GROUND AND- THAT
CAN BE SIMILAR TO. A REAL
ESTATE SIGN OR EAT ANYTHING
THAT'S COMMONLY MAYBE NOT
PROCEED AS AN EXCAVATION BUT
YOU'RE GOING IN THERE ARE
GROUND AND BECAUSE SUBJECT-
EQUIPMENT TO DAMAGE SO- THERE'S
A LOT OF. YOU KNOW I THINK A
LOT OF DISCUSSION THAT REMAINS.
AROUND THIS THIS SUBJECT I
THINK THAT THE GOOD. S.
PRACTICES WOULD BE WARRANTED AT
SOME POINT BUT I DO THINK THERE
WILL BE A GREAT DEAL OF WORK
AS- WHEN WE COME TO THE
REGARDING THE SUBJECT
SPECIFICALLY. VERY GOOD THANK
YOU. MR ROBERT P. JEANNIE HAS A
ROBUST QUALITY ASSURANCE
PROGRAM IN PLACE. FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND IN IT IT DISCOVERED.
THE LOCATE AND MARK ISSUES MANY
YEARS BEFORE THE CPC BROUGHT
ITS CASE AGAINST THEM. OF A FOR
WHATEVER REASON THERE ARE
QUALITY ASSURANCE PROGRAM WAS
IGNORED. AND NOTHING HAPPENED
WITH THAT IT HOW IS THIS THE
GENIE N SO CAL GAS PROMOTING
THE ISSUES RAISED BY THEIR A
QUALITY ASSURANCE PROGRAM.
WHILE IN JAIL ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT YOU KNOW WE STRONGLY FEEL
CONFIDENT IS THAT WE HAVE- A
STRONG. A STRONG CULTURE THAT
ALLOWS THE EMPLOYEE TO RAISE
CONCERNS OR QUESTIONS.
REGARDING TO THE EXTENT SUCH AS
YOU KNOW IF THEY DON'T FEEL
COMFORTABLE ON DOING SOMETHING
AT THE AT THE HAVE THE EVERYONE
HAS THE AUTHORITY TO STOP THE
JOB. WHICH IS AND WHAT THAT
MEANS IS YOU KNOW THEY'RE NOT
GONNA -CEED
SUPREMACY PERSPECTIVE UNTIL
THEY GET THE SUPPORT OR OF
KNOWLEDGE MEANT. THAT HE THEY
CAN MOVE FORWARD IN A SAFE
MANNER. WITH THAT. IT ALLOWS US
TO REALLY VALUE IS REALLY OVER
THE COMMUNICATION LINES ALL THE
WAY FROM THAT FRONTLINE EMPLOY.
ALL THE WAY TO OUR OUR
EXECUTIVES AT THE TOP LEVEL.
WHERE THEY ACKNOWLEDGE THAT AND
NO KNOWLEDGE OF EMPLOYEES TO
IDENTIFY WHEN THEIR SPECIFIC
ISSUES AND THEN. AS PART OF OUR
AS FAR QUALITY ASSURANCE WERE
MONITORING AND LIKE I MENTIONED
BEFORE. YOU KNOW THOSE
SENTENCES WERE WERE AT FAULT
WE'RE LOOKING AT WHERE IS
IMPROVEMENTS THAT WE CAN DO
WHETHER IT'S TRAINING FOR THAT
EMPLOYEE TO GIVEN. THE RIGHT
TRAINING THAT THEY HAVE THAT
WHAT THEY KNOW WHAT TO DO TO
DO. LOOKING FOR OPPORTUNITIES
HAVE FOR TOOLS COOLEY IS ALSO A
BIG ONE- TO MAKING IT HAPPEN TO
A RECORD KEEPING TO MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE THE RIGHT RIGHT
CORRECT RECORDKEEPING PROCESSES
IN PLACE. TO ALSO LOOKING FOR
LOOKING WHAT CAN WE DO TO
PREVENT DAMAGES. YOU KNOW ONE
THING THAT WE STARTED DOING FOR
NEW INSTALLATIONS IS
INSTALLING. ARE WE GONNA
SELLING HIS WIRE MESH THE GOAL
THE CROSSOVER HIGH PRIORITY
LINES I'M IN SUCH A WAY THAT IT
IT SERVES AS A DETERRENT. WHEN
AN EXCAVATOR. ARM EXPOSES THE
DISPLAY CAN ACTUALLY BACK WHOLE
GET CAUGHT ON BECAUSE AS MUCH
ROBUST DEVICE. I'M SO WE WE'VE
HAD A LOT OF SUCCESS WITH THAT
AND WE'VE NOW EXPORTS SPENDING
THAT TO ALL OUR LINES. ON
STARTING NEXT YEAR WILL BE
UTILIZING THAT WIRE MESH WITH
SO WE'RE LOOKING AT DIFFERENT
WAYS. TO LEVERAGE. AND PROMOTE
DAMAGES WERE FACILITIES. PHONE
IN THE ONLINE PORTAL YOU'VE
REMOVED THE ABILITY TO ADD
COMMENTS TO TICKET SUBMISSIONS.
WHAT WAS THE RATIONALE OR
THINKING BEHIND THAT. SO THERE
THERE ARE TWO FLAVORS TO
CREATING TICKETS ONLINE. FIRST
FIRST OF ALL WE PREFER TO
CREATE THE TICKET ONLINE
BECAUSE AS AWARENESS INCREASES
IN VOLUME INCREASES. WE DON'T
WANT A LINEAR- CORRELATION TO
THE NUMBER OF CALL CENTER
AGENTS THAT WE HAVE TO HIRE AS
THE VOLUME GOES UP WE DON'T
WANT TO CONTINUE OUR STAFF TO
GO THROUGH THE ROOF BECAUSE
UTILITY OWNERS FUND US AND
THEREFORE THERE BILLS GO UP AND
THEN BUILD SMALL MEMBERS
COMPLAIN AND DON'T PARTICIPATE
AND SO. WE TRY TO BE EFFICIENT
BY DOING IT ONLINE THAT BEING
SAID THERE ARE TWO FLAVORS ONE
IS THE ONE IT'S FOR A SINGLE
ADDRESS. SUCH AS A HOMEOWNER
WORKING IN THEIR OWN YARD AND
THAT ONE DOESN'T REQUIRE ANY
TRAINING WE TRY TO HAVEIT BE-
SELECT FROM THE DROP DOWN LIST
YOU KNOW WHAT COUNTY ARE YOU
WORKING IN WHAT CITY WHAT'S
YOUR ADDRESS WHAT PART OF THE
PROPERTY DO YOU WANT CHECK FOR
UTILITIES AND THAT'S IT. IT'S
JUST BASIC THEN FOR EXCAVATORS
OF OTHER TYPES ANY OTHER THING
THAT'S MORE COMPLICATED AND
SOME OF THEM GET EXTREMELY
COMPLICATED WE ACTUALLY GIVE
THEM THE SAME SOFTWARE THAT OUR
CALL CENTRE AGENTS USE AND
TEACH THEM HOW TO USE IT. BUT
IT'S MUCH MORE COMPLEX AND SO
YOU CAN'T JUST HAVE THAT OPEN
TO THE PUBLIC WITH NO TRAINING
TO DO THAT SO WE FOUND THAT-
PROFESSIONAL EXCAVATORS WERE-
SNEAKING AROUND THE- DROPDOWN
LIMITATIONS. BECAUSE WHAT WE
WOULD HAVE A PLACE WAS- YOU
KNOW YOU'RE SINGLE ADDRESS ONE
TWO THREE MAIN STREET AND THEN
FOR WHAT PART OF THE PROPERTY
DE WANT MARKED ENTIRE LOT FRONT
REAR NORTH SOUTHEAST WEST. AND
THEN WE HAVE ONE THAT WAS OTHER
AND THEN IN OTHER WE ENVISION
THAT THEY WOULD SAY ALL I ONLY
WANT A TEN FOOT RADIUS AROUND
THE MAILBOX BECAUSE I'M ONLY
REPLACE THE MAILBOX AT ONLY MY
WHOLE YARD MARKED I ONLY WANT
THE MAILBOX. BUT WHAT WE WERE
FIGHTING WITH THE CONTRACTORS
WERE GOING IN OTHER AND THEN
THEY WOULD TYPE OUT THIS LONG
EXPLANATION ABOUT STARTED THIS
ADDRESS AND CONTINUE FOR THREE
BLOCKS DOWN THE STREET AND THEN
TURN RIGHT AND SO ON MEANWHILE
THE SYSTEM IS ONLY MAPPED IT
OUT THE ONE ADDRESS AND
NOTIFIED THE UTILITY OWNERS AT
THAT ADDRESS. LEAVING OFF
EVERYTHING ELSE. THAT THEY PUT
IN THE TEXT SO WE TOOK AWAY THE
ABILITY TO PUT IN FREE TEXT IN
THE FLAVOR. THAT IS FOR
HOMEOWNERS ALL THAT'S FOR THE
SINGLE ADDRESS WITH NO
TRAINING. THAT THE ROBUST ONE
THAT'S DESIGNED FOR HIGH VOLUME
EXCAVATORS THAT HAVE TO WATCH A
VIDEO AND- CONFIRM THAT THEY'VE
BEEN TRAINED THEY STILL HAVE
FREE ACCESS TO DO ANYTHING AND
EVERYTHING. HE SAID. THANK YOU
FOR THAT EXPLANATION. THE. HEY
CPUC M. AND AS YOU KNOW I ASKED
THE PREVIOUS PANEL ABOUT THE
PARTNER AGENCIES IN THE
SUPPORTING THE- THEIR EDUCATION
IN LIEU OF FINE- STANDS AS THE
CPUC CONTEMPLATED THAT APPROACH
AND HOW WOULD IT FIT INTO THEIR
ENFORCEMENT. STRUCTURE I THINK
AGAIN AS FAR AS CONTEMPLATING
THAT'S AS I ALLUDED EARLIER IS
ONE OF THE ELEMENTS SO THE NINE
ELEMENTS HAVING THAT IS A
PROCESS. OF IT FOR OFFENDERS SO
WITH WITH THE UTILITIES WE
DON'T REGULATE THE CONTRACTORS
AND IN THE EXCAVATORS OTHER
THAN THE NON OTHER THAN THE
UTILITY FOLKS INVOLVED BUT-
AGAIN FROM OUR PROCESS IT'S
LOOKING AT THE DAMAGES FROM THE
UTILITY AND- IS IT A RETRAINING
ISSUE IS THE IS THAT A- WHAT
WAS DID THE- INCIDENT- DAMAGE
OCCUR AS A RESULT OF. A SIGNAL
TRANSFER TO SOMETHING ELSE SO
IS IT SOMETHING I WAS AVOIDABLE
OR IS IT SOMETHING THAT THE
PERSON IS COMPLETELY DIDN'T
FOLLOW PROCEDURE SO. I THINK
FROM OUR END IN TERMS OF THE
APPLICATION OF THE EMPLOYEES ON
THE LOCATORS INVOLVED FOR THE
OPERATORS IT'S A MATTER OF HOW
ARE THEY BEING TRAINED WHAT'S A
RETRAINING- AND THAT'S REALLY
OUR EDUCATION KUMAR THE REST OF
IT THAT THAT DIFFERS BACK TO
CONTRACTORS AND OTHER FOLKS. WE
WOULD WE WERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROCESS OF HAVING AN EDUCATION
HAVING THAT IS A IN LIEU OF A
OF A HEAVY FINE. AND HAVING
SOME SORT OF AN ESCALATION IN
FINES FOR THE PARTY INVOLVED.
SO IF THEY DON'T CHANGE ADDED
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE REPEAT
OFFENSES SO THAT'S THE WAY WE
LOOKED AT IT THAT'S WHO WE CAN
APPLY IT FOR IS THE UTILITIES
OWN AND YOU KNOW STAFF
PERFORMING THE ACTIVITIES. AND
A AND YOU KNOW LOOKING AT THEIR
PROCESSES FOR RETRAINING AND
RECALL FIND WE HAVE AT LEAST
FOR THE GAS EITHER STRICT
REGULATIONS IN TERMS OF
OPERATORS SEVEN BECAUSE OF
FOLKS DOING ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
QUALIFIED ON THOSE TASKS. AND
SO WAS THIS INDIVIDUAL
QUALIFIED DID THE YOU KNOW IS
THERE AN AREA FOR IMPROVEMENT
AND THEN THAT INDIVIDUALS
QUALIFICATION IS AN AREA FOR
IMPROVING THE OVERALL
QUALIFICATION FOR THE TASK SO
YOU CAN LOOK AT A LOT OF
PERSPECTIVES IN TERMS OF HOW TO
HOW TO APPLY THAT. UP THAT'S
THE EXTENT OF HOW WE CAN LOOK
AT IT. IN TERMS OF. HOW CAN YOU
IMPROVING OPERATORS PROCESSES.
THANK YOU. I BELIEVE FOR THE
REGISTRAR DAVID VOTE FROM THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD
IS HERE HOW ARE YOU DOING IF
YOU COULD COME UP I JUST HAVE A
QUESTION RELATED TO THE SAME.
WHO V. M. THE ISSUE OF HAS THE
BOARD CONTEMPLATED THE BIG
BOARD'S ENFORCEMENT STRUCTURE
AND HOW HOW TODAY ARE YOU
DEALING WITH OR HE HANDLING THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE DIG
BOARD RELATED TO VIOLATIONS AND
OTHER. WELL I AM PLEASED TO
REPORT THAT WE WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH DR TONY MORAN
KNOWN AS STAFF IN PUTTING
TOGETHER A PROCESSES FOR WE
START RECEIVING REFERRALS FROM
THEM I DON'T BELIEVE WE
RECEIVED A REFERRALS TODAY. BUT
WHAT WE WORKED OUT IS THAT
THEY'LL MAKE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON WHAT TYPE OF
ACTION IS APPROPRIATE FOR THAT
VIOLATION OF THIS RULE VERY
QUICKLY TOUCH ON THE OPTIONS
ARE AVAILABLE. THE FIRST WOULD
BE AN ADVISORY NOTICE US WE'RE
CURRENTLY USING TODAY WE ARE
RECEIVING COMPLAINTS FROM SOAK
SO THE CALIFORNIA GAS AND
OTHERS AND IF WHAT THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR IS TO BE MADE WHOLE
MEETING THERE WAS A HAT AND
THERE'S RESTITUTION OR THE DOW
IS UP THE PAID THEM THE
CONTRACTORS WILLING TO PAY
THOSE DAMAGES AND ATTEND THEIR
TRAINING PROGRAM. IN ADVISORY
NOTICE NOTICE MAY BE
APPROPRIATE BUT I THINK WILLIAM
MORE LIKELY TO SEE FROM THE
DECK SAVE BOARD IS A SITUATION
WHERE THERE MAY BE DISCLOSURE
REQUIRED ON THAT LICENSE WE
HAVE WHAT'S KNOWN AS A LETTER
OF ADMONISHMENT AND THUS THAT
CITY- A LETTER THAT WE ISSUE
FOR THE VIOLATION. BY IT WILL
GENERALLY HAVE IN ORDER TO
ATTEND TRAINING BY OUR PARTNERS
LET GO THROUGH A TRAINING
PROGRAM IT PROVIDES FOR ONE
YEAR DISCLOSURE ON THE LICENSE.
A SITUATION THOUGH WHERE
THERE'S BEEN A STRIKE AND
THERE'S BEEN DAMAGES THAT OCCUR
AND THE CONTRACTOR DOESN'T WANT
TO PAY DAMAGES TO THAT PUBLIC
UTILITY- THAT WOULD LIKELY
RESULT IN ADMINISTRATIVE
CITATION BECAUSE A CITATION HAS
THE ABILITY TO INCLUDED ORDER
OF CORRECTION TO PAY
RESTITUTION TO SOMEONE A
CITATION WOULD INCLUDE. A FIVE
YEAR- DISCLOSURE ON THE LICENSE
AND THEN FOR THE VERY SERIOUS
MATTERS WERE YOU MAY HAVE A
FATALITY OF A REPEAT OFFENDER
BUT AGAIN WOULD BE WORKING WITH
THE DIG SAY FOR TO SEE IF THIS
WAS THE APPROPRIATE DISCIPLINE
THAT COULD BE SUSPENSION OR
REVOCATION OF THE LICENSE. WAS
WAS SAY TODAY OUR FIRST THING
IS EDUCATION- WERE VERY I THEY
WERE VERY PROACTIVE IN
INFORMATION IS ON OUR WEBSITE
IN OUR CONSUMER GUIDES ON WHAT
WE'RE DOING TO HELP OUT
REGIONALLY CONSUMERS. BUT TO
THE LICENSEES SO THEY
UNDERSTAND THE NEED TO CALL.
THE MAJORITY OF THE ACTIONS WE
TAKE OUR THE ADVISORY NOTICE
WHICH IS NOT. THIS CLOSABLE BUT
IT DOES ACHIEVE. WHAT WE
BELIEVE IS THE EDUCATION A
COMPLIANCE COMPONENT. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE THE
GOOD WORK THAT THEIR
CONTRACTORS LICENSE BOARD IS
DOING. AND CONTINUES TO DO TO
A- TO FACILITATE THIS ISSUE
RELATED TO THE DIG SAFE BOARD
IN THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS BUT
ALSO THE GREAT WORK YOU DO
ELSEWHERE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE TODAY YES MAY
TWENTY. OF IT IN RELATION JUST
BEFORE YOU SIT DOWN SIR- I KNOW
MANY OTHER STATES REQUIRE
CONTINUING EDUCATION CREDITS
RELATED TO BEING A PROFESSIONAL
EXCAVATOR. SUCH AS THAT IF YOU
GET YOUR LICENSE ONE TIME- WHEN
YOU'RE TWENTY FIVE. BUT THEN
YOU CONTINUE TO DIG FOR A FORTY
YEAR CAREER. HOW DO WE ENSURE
THAT CONTRACTORS ARE STAYING UP
TO DATE ON- BEST PRACTICES AND
THINGS LIKE THAT RELATED TO
EXCAVATION. THEIR TALK AT CECIL
B. ABOUT REQUIRING. AT LEAST
FOR EXCAVATION RELATED
CONTRACTING TO HAVE CONTINUING
EDUCATION TO ENSURE THAT THEY
KNOW THE LAW CHANGES AND SO
FORTH. WELL YEAH WHAT THEY DO
WANT TO CONFIRM THAT WHILE I
WAS. ATTENDING THIS MEETING I
CONFIRM THAT OUR TRADE EXAM FOR
NEW LICENSEES DOES INCLUDE THE
REQUIREMENT TO CALL A ONE LINE
SO WE DID. WE DID VERIFY THAT
WE'RE ALSO DEVELOPING WEBINARS
AND PODCASTS. WEBINARS AND
TRAINING COURSES FOR FAILURE TO
COMPLY WITH CODE REQUIREMENTS
SO THIS COULD BE PART OF THAT.
IS FAR AS A MAN IT MANDATED
CONTINUE EDUCATION TRAINING
COMPONENT THE LAWS ARE
CURRENTLY PROVIDE FOR THAT. BUT
IN THE EVENT THAT WE FIND
SOMEBODY'S WILEY Là OWSLEY
WANT TO GET THE WORD OUT WE
WANT TO WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE DIG SAY POURED. IN IN OUR
WITH OUR YOU TUBE CHANNEL WITH
OUR OUR PODCASTS WEBINARS AND
ARE. ON OUR MONTHLY MEETINGS
THAT WE HAVE WITH APPLICANTS
AND INDUSTRY STATEWIDE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT. THE END.
CHAUDHRY THE M. S. THE D. BOARD
DURING THE LAST PANEL ABOUT
THEIR MO YOU WITH THIS IF YOU
SEE AND WHETHER OR NOT THE
BOARD WAS INVOLVED IN THE P.
JEANNIE LOCATE AND MARK
PROCEEDINGS AND SAID INSIDE THE
SPECIFIC CASE- DOES THE CPUC
HAVE CONFIDENCE THAT THE
PROGRAMS IDENTIFIED IN P.
GENIES. PROGRAM ARE NOT
SYMPTOMATIC OF LARGER ISSUES IN
THE DIG SAFE COMMUNITY. WE WILL
CONTINUE WE LOOK AT THAT WERE
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THAT IN
TERMS OF OUR INSPECTIONS- AND
INCIDENTS INVESTIGATIONS AND
REVIEW OF THE DATA THAT WE GET.
UP BY THE BY THE UTILITIES UP.
A GAS AT THE INDUSTRY FOR THE
REPORTING. AND. BASED ON THE
INSPECTIONS BASED ON WHAT WE'RE
SAYING THERE'S CERTAINLY AREAS
AS IT'S BEEN NOTED BEFORE
THERE'S MISS MARKS AND LATE
TICKETS AND THINGS ARE
OCCURRING I AND NUMBER AVOID
WILL SUMMER NINE AND- YOU KNOW
AGAIN LOOKING A CUBIC UC'S
LOOKING AT THOSE. BUT AS FAR AS
OVERALL ISSUES OF THAT TYPE
THAT'S NOT BEEN A GAS
INSPECTIONS A WE'VE DONE SO
FAR. THAT WE'RE SEEING THAT IS
AT ISSUE. YOU KNOW IT THE AGAIN
THE THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT OF
THE QUEUE IF YOU SEE PROGRAMS.
BUT AS FAR AS ISSUES YES
THERE'S RIGHT AREAS THERE'S IT
CERTAINLY IN AREAS FOR
IMPROVEMENT IN TERMS OF.
GETTING ACCURACY GETTING
TICKETS MARKED ON TIME AVOIDING
DAMAGES BY THE UTILITIES OWN-
EXCAVATION ACTIVITIES. BUT A
OVERALL IT'S NOT A LARGE
TRAINED- THAT THAT WE'RE
OBSERVING OKAY. GOOD AND HOW
HOW IS YOUR RELATIONSHIP WITH
IT TAKES A BOARD ON ME ARE YOU
WORKING. THROUGH THAT MO USED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS A-
THE COMMUNICATION OF THE ISSUES
BECAUSE YOU'RE REALLY AT THE
HEART OF. THE ENFORCEMENT AND
MOST OF THOSE PROBLEMS WILL
WIND UP IN YOUR LAP AT SOME
POINT IN TIME I WOULD THINK WE
AGAIN WE'VE- YEAH WE'VE DONE
INCIDENT DESTINATIONS OF
DICKENS. FOR A LONG TIME THIS
SO AS FAR AS THE ISSUES THAT
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT NHà. WE
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH A BIG
BOARD- TO IDENTIFY HOW THE DATA
IS GOING TO BE RECEIVED WHAT.
ARE YOU KNOW HOW CAN WE
ACCOMMODATE EACH OTHER'S NEEDS
I MEAN OTHER THAN ESTABLISHING
THE ANIMAL YOU WE HAVEN'T HAD
ANY. RECENT MEETINGS OR
DISCUSSIONS ON THAT END. BUT
CERTAINLY IN IN TERMS OF HOW WE
CAN. RECEIVE THAT AND YOU KNOW.
AT SOME POINT WE'VE GOT TO
DECIDE HOW WE'RE GOING TO
PROCESS THOSE AS WELL. BUT WE
CERTAINLY ANTICIPATE THERE
WOULD BE MORE BECAUSE IT. THERE
ARE MORE HITS THAN TEN YEAH
WE'RE WE'RE ABLE TO
INVESTIGATE- AND IF SOME OF
THOSE COME OUR WAY THAN THAT
THAT WOULD BE SOME ADDITIONAL
WORK THAT WE NEED TO DO. BUT AS
YOU KNOW AS FAR AS ANY RECENT
DISCUSSIONS ON THE ANIMAL YOU I
DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S BEEN
ANYTHING MORE. THAN THEM ONCE
WE ESTABLISHED. DR MARINA. AND
MAYBE MAYBE I CAN JUST ADD-
CERTAINLY THERE'S BEEN
DISCUSSIONS- BETWEEN OUR
INVESTIGATORS. AND PC AND SEE
NEIL BUT THERE'S ALSO BEEN SOME
DISCUSSIONS- BETWEEN OUR
ATTORNEYS. AND AS I THINK WE
ALL KNOW THE PC IS A THE AGENCY
WHERE YOU WANT TO. MAKE SURE
YOU UNDERSTAND THEIR LAWS
BEFORE YOU JUMPING INTO THEIR
SO THERE HAVE BEEN DISCUSSIONS
AT THAT ATTORNEY LEVELS WELL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FOR THE
TWENTY EIGHT. THE BIG BOARD
DISCUSSED IN THEIR TESTIMONY
THE NEED FOR MORE DATA. TO
TRACK TRENDS INDIANS IN ORDER
TO BETTER TAILOR THEIR
EDUCATION PROGRAM TO SPECIFIC
TASKS AS WE'VE SEEN. WE ALSO
DISCUSSED THE NEED TO MANDATE A
CALL. TO A ONE ONE IN THE EVENT
OF A DEACON ESPECIALLY CLOSING
THE LOOP ON A CALL BEFORE YOU
DIG TO INCLUDE A CALL AFTER YOU
TAKE. A OR DIG INTO SOMETHING-
BOTH OF THESE TOPICS CENTER AND
THE OPERATIONS AT THE ONE CALL
CENTERS AND- A RELIANCE ON YOUR
PARTICIPATION IN THAT TO MAKE
IT WORK OR JUST. EAT WITH THE
PASSAGE OF AB ELEVEN SIXTY SIX
OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE
EARLIER THIS YEAR. REQUIRED
REQUIRING ELECTRIC ELECTRONIC
POSITIVE RESPONSE TO ONE CALL
CENTERS AFTER LOCATING MARK.
HOW DO YOU FORESEE THE ONE CALL
CENTERS. ADJUSTING TO THESE NEW
REQUIREMENTS. THE GREAT
QUESTION FIRST THE I WANT TO
SAY THAT WE ARE VERY PLEASED
WELL I CAN'T SPEAK FOR MYSELF
I'M CONFIDENT THAT- DEALER
WOULD AGREE WITH ME BUT I WON'T
PUT WORDS IN IN THEIR MOUTH-
BUT USA NORTH IS VERY PLEASED
WITH BOTH OF THESE- NEW
DEVELOPMENTS- WE'D BE HAPPY TO
RECEIVE. A RECALL- REPORTS OF
DAMAGE OF EVERY TYPE BECUSE
THEN WE HAVE THE DATA SO THEN
WE CAN KNOW HOW TO TARGET OUR
EDUCATION BECAUSE RIGHT NOW- NO
OFFENSE TO THE DIG SAKE BOARD
BUT THEY'RE STILL IN THEIR
INFANCY IN SO RIGHT NOW THE-
EDUCATION IS BEING DONE BY US-
MEANING THE TO NOTIFICATION-CENTERS AN THEN YOU KNOW SOME-
FACILITY OPERATORS DO THAT-
VERY WELL ALSO AND HAVE ROBUST
PROGRAM SUCH A SO CAL GAS AND
P. JEANNIE AND OTHERS BUT THEN
THERE ARE MANY WHO DO NOTHING.
I EVEN LARGE COMPANIES IT'S NOT
ON THEIR RADAR SO ANYWAY THE I
THINK YOU I THINK IT WOULD BE
FAIR TO SAY THAT- THE ONE CALL
CENTERS ARE DOING A VERY LARGE
PERCENTAGE OF THE EDUCATION
THAT'S HAPPENING STATEWIDE
RIGHT NOW SO WE'D BE HAPPY TO
SO I'M NOT WORRIED ABOUT IT
FROM A RESOURCES POINT OF VIEW
ABOUT RECEIVING THE NOTICES
WILL BE HAPPY TO TAKE IT WE
DON'T SEE ANY BARRIERS AND NO
BARRIERS THE SYSTEMS ALREADY IN
PLACE WE CAN DO IT ONLINE TOO
SO WANT TO BE A RESOURCES ISSUE
NO PROBLEM- THE ELECTRON PAS
RESPONSE THAT'S A BIG. DEAL
THAT. THAT IS GOOD. IT'S GOING
TO MAKE THE WORLD SAFER THIS IS
PROVEN TO BE THE CASE IN MANY
STATES THAT HAVE THIS THEIR
STATE THAT I'VE HAD THIS FOR
DECADES AND THIRD AND THERE'RE
DAMAGE. RATES ARE SIGNIFICANTLY
LOWER. HOWEVER RIGHTNOW IT'S
VOLUNTARY AS IT STARTED IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND SO NOW IT
BECOMES MANDATORY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. WHICH IS A GOOD THING.
OTHERS TALK ABOUT ALLOWING-
EXEMPTIONS FOR MORE TIME FOR
OPERATORS TO- COMPLY WITH THAT
REQUIREMENT I WOULD- STRONGLY
RECOMMEND THERE BE NO
EXEMPTIONS BECAUSE THIS. IS
BECAUSE OF THERE'S EVEN ONE
EXEMPTION IT'S STILL VOLUNTARY.
BASICALLY AND THE CONTRACTORS
ARE NOT GOING TO USE IT. UNTIL
THEY KNOW THAT IT'S MANDATORY.
THE OTHER ASPECT IS THE WORDING
REQUIRES THE EXCAVATOR THE-
FACILITY OPERATORS TO RESPOND
TO THE SYSTEM BUT THE WORDING
OF THAT BILL DOES NOT REQUIRE
THE EXCAVATOR TO CHECK THE
SYSTEM BEFORE HE TAKES. AND I
THINK THAT IS A PART THAT IS
MISSING. BECAUSE WHAT GOOD DOES
IT DO IF ALL THE FACILITY
OPERATORS REPLY TO THE SYSTEM
BUT THEN THE EXPANDER NEVER
LOOKS AT THAT NOW I THINK THE
GOOD ONES WILL. BECAUSE THEY'RE
GOOD BUT THE OTHER ONES WON'T
AND SO I- THE OTHER THING IS.
THAT THE FUTURE OF THIS IS WHAT
WE CALL IN THE INDUSTRY ENHANCE
THE POSITIVE RESPONSE WERE NOT
ONLY IS IT. A SO CAL GAS. OF
INDICATED IN THE SYSTEM THAT
THEY MARK THE LINE. BUT NOW
THEY'VE ALSO UPLOADED
ATTACHMENTS SUCH AS PICTURES
MARKINGS AND LANDS. AND THE
OTHER WAY THE EXCAVATOR COULD
DO THAT IN THE BEGINNING THEY
CAN SEND PICTURES OF THE
DELINEATION AND WHITE TO SAY
HERE'S MY DIG SITE SO THE SO
CAL GAS KNOWS THAT. YEP THEY'VE
BEEN THERE. SO MY LOCATOR IS
GONNA BE ABLE TO FIND THE DIG
SITE CORRECTLY AS WEL AS THEIR
PLANS AND NOW THE PARTIES ARE
TALKING. AND IF THEY WANT TO
NEGOTIATE A LATER START TIME
BECAUSE THE PROJECT IS BIGGER
THERE- OTHER FACILITIES IN THE
WAY THAT CAN'T BE LOCATE AND
THINGS LIKE THAT THAT CAN ALL
BE DOCUMENTED IN THE SYSTEM.
AND THEN REGULATORS LIKE SNAIL
CAN COME IN AND- AND SEE THE
HISTORY THERE. SO THAT THERE IS
A DAMAGE AND THE HE SAID SHE
SAID STUFF. IS GOES AWAY A
LITTLE BIT MORE IF IT CAN ALL
BE. CENTRALIZED SO THAT'S WHERE
ENVISIONED THE FUTURE GOING-
AND I'D LIKE TO. SEE
LEGISLATION GET TO THAT POINT-
I AM NOT AWARE OF ANY STATE TO
HAS THAT IS MANDATORY I KNOW
NORTH CAROLINA HAS IT
VOLUNTARILY TO. THIS ENHANCED
BUILT WHAT THE- ATTACHMENTS
BEING IN PLACE BUT I THINK THAT
CAN. YOU KNOW IF WE'RE GOING TO
DO IT I THINK WE OUGHT TO DO
IT. AND NOT JUST THE APART TELL
WHEN IT I THINK WE OUGHT TO
JUMP RIGHT IN AND BECOME A
LEADER LIKE CALIFORNIA STRIVE
TO BE IN EVERY WAY. INSTEAD OF
A RELUCTANT FOLLOWER LIKE WE
ARE NOW HIGHLIGHTED APPROACH
WHICH ONE. THANK YOU. MISTER
BOROUGH AT THE. THANK SAFE
BORDERS YOU HEARD IS CLOSE TO
THEM OF A FINANCIAL DEFICIT.
AND CURRENTLY THERE FUNDING
ARISES FROM A FEE ON THE
OPERATORS AS MR WHEN HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT THAT EVERYTHING
SEEMS TO GO TO FEED TO THE
OPERATORS- I'VE HEARD ARGUMENTS
THAT A SMALL FEE ON EXCAVATORS
COULD FACILITATE MORE GREATER
BY IN ON THE THAT FROM THE
ACTUATOR COMMUNITY. TO THE WORK
OBJECTIVES OF THE DIG SAY FORD-
WHAT DO YOU FEEL THAT IT. THAT
COULD ACHIEVE THOSE THAT AIM
AND WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT
COULD WORK IN THE FUTURE A- I
THINK THE OPTION IS THERE BUT I
THINK THERE'S A NEED FOR A MUCH
MORE DISCUSSION IN THAT REGARD
SIMPLY BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO
DIS INCENTIVIZE. AND YOU KNOW I
DEAL WITH A LARGER CONTRACTORS
THAT THEY MAY NOT BE SUCH A BIG
DEAL BUT IF YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE SMALLER GUYS THE GUYS
WHO ARE DOING THIS ON A REGULAR
BASIS WE DON'T CREATE A
DISINCENTIVE. FOR THEM TO CALL
EIGHT ONE ONE BECAUSE NOW
THERE'S A PRICE TAG ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT SO IF YOU TAKE THAT
INTO CONSIDERATION. YOU KNOW I
THINK THE DOORS OPEN TO HAVE
THIS CONVERSATION IT WOULD BE
GOOD I YOU KNO MAYBE SOME
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS YES THAT
AND SEE HOW WE CAN BEST MOVE
FORWARD WITH THAT. WOULD BE
GREAT. OF THOSE THIS IS THE END
OF MY QUESTIONS DO YOU HAVE ANY
INTRICATE YOUR FEELING. I JUST
TOOK NOTE OF YOUR SUGGESTION
ABOUT THE LEGISLATION I THINK
THAT SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD
DISCUSS IF THAT. IS RIGHT FOR
SOMETHING THIS YEAR. THANK YOU
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS IS
QUITE ENLIGHTENING AND- REALLY
QUITE TO THINK PRODUCTIVE IN
TERMS OF THE INFORMATION AND
WHERE WE GO FORWARD BUT BEFORE
WE CONCLUDE WE WILL OPEN THIS
TO PUBLIC COMMENT IF ANYONE
WOULD LIKE TO. MAKE A COMMENT-
TODAVíA FEEL FREE TO. COME
FORWARD. NO IS NEVER JUST USE.
ALL THESE PEOPLE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR TODD BLOOM SIGN
FOR THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION GOT
SOME NOTES BUT PROBABLY WON'T
EVEN USE THOSE FIRST WANT TO
COMPLEMENT AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR YOUR DOG KITTY AND
CONSISTENT INTEREST IN THIS
AREA OF THE U. I. OVER THAT
MEDIAN I DO. DOWN THE HALL YEAH
AND YOU KNOW THE BIGGEST POINT
THAT I TOOK AWAY FROM THAT
MEETING WAS WHEN PEOPLE AND
EXCAVATORS CALL EIGHT ONE ONE-
THAT THE POSSIBILITY OF DAMAGES
GO TREMENDOUSLY DOWN A WHICH IS
WHAT I THOUGHT TOO WELL WHAT I
THINK STILL DOES THIS PROCESS
REALLY REALLY ISN'T AND AS WE
GET INTO SOME OF THE MORE
DETAILS- PRESENTATIONS. IN AN
AND DETAILED DISCUSSIONS YOU
KNOW YOU. THERE'S SOME. THE
DETAILS THAT NEED TO NEED TO BE
WORKED OUT OF COURSE. WHAT ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I THINK WE
SHOULD COMPLEMENT TO IS OUT OF
THE P. UC'S INVESTIGATION- THAT
HAS NOT BEEN DISCUSSED
WHATSOEVR IN ANY OF THE DIXIE
FOR BOARD MEETINGS WHICH IS
INTERESTING BECAUSE I THINK
THAT A LOT OF INFORMATION CAN
BE GLEANED FROM THAT. AND TAKE
IN AND LOOKED AT OKAY WHAT ARE
SOME SCENARIOS HAT WE COULD
FIX SOME OF THE PROBLEMS THAT
WE SAW- IN IN IN THAT
INVESTIGATION ONE OF THEM WAS
AB ELEVEN SIXTY SIX BY MR
LEVINE- THAT SPECIFICALLY WILL
ENSURE THAT. THE TICKETS AREN'T
GOING TO BE. SAY THIS PLAYED A
FABRICATED OR OR OR CHANGED
THAT WON'T HAPPEN ANYMORE
INJURY BE ELEVEN SIXTY SIX
THAT'S VERY VERY POSITIVE- ONE
THING I WOULD LIKE TO. TO
CLARIFY IN AND I DONALD
SLIGHTLY MISLEADING- WAS THAT
THE DAMAGES ARE NOT BEING
REPORTED WHATSOEVER. AND THAT'S
SIMPLY NOT THE CASE A SECTION
FORTY TWO SIXTEEN SEE ONE- IT
IN IN IN AN INSTANT WHEN
EXCAVATOR DAMAGES SOMETHING
UNDERGROUND FIRST. FIRST CALL
OF COURSE IS GOING TO BE NINE
ONE ONE IF SOMEONE WAS INJURED-
AND THEN THE STATUTE ALSO
REQUIRES. THE CON THE EXCAVATOR
TO CONTACT THE OPERATOR'S WELL-
SO THAT THERE IS COMMUNICATION
GOING ON- IT'S NOT AS IF WHILE
WE'RE NOT GONNA CALL ANYONE AND
NOT FOLLOW THROUGH- A COUPLE
OTHER POINTS. AND I DIDN'T SAY
SO SHOULD COMPLEMENT THE BOARD
AS WELL THEY THEY'VE DONE AN
OUTSTANDING JOB THEY'VE BEEN
VERY VERY THOROUGH VERY
THOROUGH. VERY PROFESSIONAL OF
THE PROVIDED OF SOMETHING THAT
WE TALKED ABOUT IN IN THE
MEETINGS YEARS AGO A VENUE FOR
OPERATORS AND EXCAVATORS TO
COME TOGETHER ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO COME TOGETHER.
AND THAT'S BEEN EXTRAORDINARILY
POSITIVE IN THE WORK PRODUCT
THEY BRING OUT THE- PRODUCED-
IS EXTRAORDINARY TO VERY
DETAILED VERY THOROUGH SO WITH
OUTSTANDING JOB THAT THEY'VE
DONE. I THINK SCCA MY CLIENT
WOULD LIKE TO SEE. A LITTLE BIT
MORE MOVEMENT TOWARDS A
DEVELOPING STANDARDS- WE WE'VE
THE STATUTE SPECIFICALLY SPELL
OUT TO THREE OR FOUR HOURS VERY
SPECIFIC THINGS THE BOARD
SHOULD BE DOING. DEVELOPING
STANDARDS EDUCATING OUT REGION
INVESTIGATIONS WE'VE ALWAYS
THOUGHT HAT THROUGH THE
INVESTIGATION PROCESS FINDING
OUT OKAY WHO'S NOT CALLING. YOU
KNOW WHAT GEOGRAPHICAL AREAS
DON'T CALL THROUGH THAT YOU
THROUGH THAT INVESTIGATION THEN
YOU CAN FOCUS THE EDUCATION
SPECIFICALLY TOWARDS WHERE
THERE'S- PEOPLE ARE CALLING A
WERE THERE'S ISSUES- IN IN THE
FIRST SENT. FIRST SET OF
REGULATIONS THAT CAME THROUGH
EARLIER THIS YEAR- THE
REGULATIONS WERE FOCUSED ON
SOME OF THE MY NEW SHOW OF. OF
THE BOARD AND THEIR PROCESS-
AND IN FACT IN NEW IF YOU'VE
EVER READ REGULATIONS ONE OF
THE THINGS THEY SAY
SPECIFICALLY THE BUT- AUTUMN.
IS WHAT THE FORTY OF THE BOARD
USED TO DOT THE REGULATION. AND
IN ALL TWENTY TWO INSTANCES IT
WAS THE PRODUCT FORTY GIVEN TO
THE BOARD RATHER THAN THAT VERY
SPECIFIC FORTY- DEALING WITH
INVESTIGATIONS ARE STANDARD SO
THAT'S SOMETHING YOU'D LIKE TO
SEE THE BOARD MOVE. IN ANOTHER
DIRECTION ARMED VERY QUICKLY ON
LIABILITY- IT DOES CONTINUE TO
BE A PROBLEM- DOWN SOUTH AYE
AYE CONTINUOUSLY HERE. REPORTS
FROM CONTRACTORS- ABOUT ABOUT
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT DAMAGES
OCCURRING- WHERE THEY DID
EVERYTHING THEY WERE SUPPOSED
TO DO- YET. WEEKS OR MONTHS
LATER THEY RECEIVE A CLAIM
FROM. OF FROM THE UTILITY
COMPANY AND WE HAD ONE
CONTRACTORS HAPPY TO. INTRODUCE
YOU TO HIM IN THAT COMPANY-
WHERE THERE WAS A FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLAR CLAIM. AND THEY THEY
FOUGHT THE CLAIM THEY SPENT
FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
ATTORNEY ATTORNEYS FEES. SIMPLY
TO DEFEND THE CLAIM AND DEFEND
THEIR. GOOD NAME AGAINST IT
THERE'S SOMETHING OF A OF A.
IMBALANCE HERE- DEALING WITH
RESOURCES AND EIGHTY THOUSAND
CONTRACTORS A RELATIVELY SMALL
COMPARED TO SOME MAJOR-
INTERNATIONALLY OR NATIONALLY
TREATED COMPANIES. THANK YOU
AGAIN CENTER THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INTEREST IN USERS STROKES AND
ONE QUESTIONS FOR OUR USE
SAYING THAT ALL OF YOUR CLIENTS.
REPORT EVERY DAY AGAIN ALL I
CAN I CERTAINLY CAN'T HARD
AFTER THERE ARE SOME THAT ARE
DEADLINE I'M I'M SURE THERE ARE
NO OKAY. AS WITH THE STATUTE
DOES THOSE REQUIRE CLIMB IN IN
ANY ANY REPUTABLE COMPANY IN IN
THE STATE IS NATURALLY GOING TO
DO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
DOING IT YOU WANT TO HAVE THE
FINAL WORD A LITTLE JUST- IN
ONE WHEN I WAS MAKING THE
COMMENTS ABOUT- DAMAGE IS NOT
BEING REPORTED I JUST MEANT
THAT NO ONE IS SEEING THE
ENTIRE BIG PICTURE. BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW IF THE LAW REQUIRES
THE EXCAVATOR TO REPORT THE
DAMAGE TO THE OPERATOR WHOSE
LIFE HE CUT. SO CAL GAS KNOWS
HOW MANY HITS THEY'VE HAD ANY
TO TELL THE ORDER GETS THAT
FROM THEIR EXHIBITORS BUT NO
ONE IS SEEING A AN AGGREGATE SO
THAT'S WHAT I WAS TRYING TO
EXPRESS EARLIER WHEN I SAID
NOTHING'S BEING REPORTED TO A-
TO A CENTRAL PLACE TO COLLECT
BECAUSE EVEN YOU KNOW SEE- CPC
HAS. GAS HITS REPORTED TO THEM
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE THE OTHER
SECTORS AND SO NO ONE ELSE HAS
IT. ON THE STATE WIDE LEVELS
WHAT I WAS TRYING TO
ILLUSTRATE. THANK YOU. OTHER
POP PUBLIC COMMENT. WE SURE DO
YOU HAVE A- COMMENT HEY I JUST
A I'VE BEEN LOOKING FOR AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REINFORCE WHAT
JAMES BROUGHT UP VERY EARLY ON
THAT AS FAR AS ANY REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS THAT COME FORTH. I
IAN WE'VE NOTED AND- STRESS
BEFORE FOR GAS SPECIALLY IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT ANY DAMAGES ANY
HIT. BE REPORTED- AND CAPTURED-
NOT JUST FOR DATA PURPOSES BUT
BECAUSE THAT IT. IT CREATES A
POTENTIAL FUTURE PROBLEM FRONT
FOR A GAS LINE SO. WE HAVE TO
BE VERY CAREFUL. NOT TO REDUCE
WHAT CURRENTLY REQUIRED. AS WE
YOU KNOW ANY IN REPORTING THAT
WE PROCEED FORWARD. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SENATOR
JANET WOULD LIKE TO. BEFORE WE
CLOSE AND IT COMES OUT VERY
GOOD THANK YOU. WELL THIS WAS
QUITE INFORMATIVE AND- ON A- I
THINK WE DISCUSSED A LOT OF
CRITICAL SAFETY ISSUES THAT-
THIS IS. THE BIG SAY FORD IS
BEEN UNDERTAKING WORKING ON
AND- TRYING TO RESOLVE AND
CREATE THAT CLARIFICATION
COMMUNICATION AND EDUCATION IN
THE- THE FIELD SO THANK YOU FOR
THE HARD WORK. THE BOARD HAS
BEEN DOING AND FOR THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE BOARD THANK
YOU. FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
PARTICIPATE AND CONTINUE TO DO
THAT. I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH. EVERYONE IN THE NEXT YEAR
SO WITH THERE ARE ISSUES THAT
WE NEED TO BRING FORWARD.
LEGISLATIVELY WILL BE HAPPY TO
LOOK AT THOSE IN AND ADDRESS
THEM SO WE ALL KNOW THAT. THESE
PROBLEMS WE TALKED ABOUT TODAY
DO NOT FIX THEMSELVES THEY NEED
A LOT OF GOOD SUPPORT GOOD
HEALTH. AND IN THE WILLINGNESS
TO DO THAT AND I THINK THE
WILLINGNESS IS IN THIS ROOM
ANSWER THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT. THE FOR THE BUSINESS. THE
HEARING TO GERMAN THANK YOU ALL